Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Lithe and liston, gentlemen, that be of free-bore blood, I shall you tell of a good ye man, his name was Robin Hood. Robin was a proud outlaw, whiles he walked on groaned, so courteous an outlaw as he was one, was never non-found. Robin stood in Bernersdale, and lended him to a tree, and by him stood little John, a good ye man was he, and also did good Scarlock, and much the miller's son. There was none inch of his body, but it was worth a grum.
感谢收听《历史的其余部分》。若想收听每周独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目，并成为我们备受喜爱的聊天社区的一员，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。倾听吧，各位绅士，你们这些血统纯正的人，我要给你们讲一个优秀小伙的故事，他的名字叫罗宾汉。罗宾是个骄傲的流亡者，当他在林间小径漫步时，从未遇见过如此温文尔雅的流亡者。罗宾站在伯内斯代尔，斜倚在一棵树旁，小约翰站在他身旁，他是个优秀的小伙，还有优秀的斯卡洛克和磨坊主的大儿子也在。他身上没有哪怕一英寸的地方，不值一个金币。
That was Kevin Costner reading A Jest of Robin Hood. I thought it was Sean Bean. No, it's Kevin Costner. Kevin Costner's a master of accents. Did you not know, Tom? So that was written sometime between probably 1450 and 1500, and it's not the earliest, but one of the earliest and probably the most important
那是凯文·科斯特纳在朗读《罗宾汉的笑话》。我以为那是肖恩·宾呢。不，那是凯文·科斯特纳。凯文·科斯特纳是模仿口音的大师。你不知道吗，汤姆？所以这大概写于1450年到1500年之间，它虽然不是最早的，但却是最早之一，也可能是最重要的一部
of all the ballads in which the story of Robin Hood first entered the English and then the world's imagination. Tom, are you a big Robin Hood fan? I love Robin Hood. I absolutely adore Robin Hood. Do you? That's good to hear. I've watched all the TV shows. I've watched all the films. I absolutely love him. And have you ever heard a Robin Hood reading as powerful and moving as that one? No, never. No, I think that was your best. So that was your, yeah. No, because it felt that it came from the heart.
所有民谣中，罗宾汉的故事正是通过它们首先进入了英国人、进而进入了全世界的想象力之中。汤姆，你是罗宾汉的超级粉丝吗？我喜欢罗宾汉。我简直爱极了罗宾汉。是吗？很高兴听到这个。我看过所有的电视节目。我看过所有的电影。我绝对爱死他了。你有没有听过比那个更充满力量、更感人的罗宾汉朗读？没有，从来没有。不，我觉得那是你最棒的一次。所以那是你的，对。不，因为我觉得那发自内心。
It was an English yeoman. Yes, it was. It was. I mean, are you a Robin Hood fan? Robin Hood and King Arthur are the reasons I got interested in history when I was about four. I still, I feel very, very sentimental about Robin Hood because I had these Lady Bird books about his adventures fighting Guy of Gisborne or whatever. And I still have them. And actually, my son, when he went to his first World Book Day at his nursery, he went as Robin Hood.
这是一个英国自耕农。是的，确实是。就是这样。我是说，你是罗宾汉的粉丝吗？罗宾汉和亚瑟王是我在大约四岁时对历史产生兴趣的原因。我仍然，我对罗宾汉有着非常非常深的情感，因为我有这些关于他的冒险经历的瓢虫读物，讲述他与吉斯伯恩的盖伊或其他什么人战斗的故事。我到现在还留着它们。事实上，我儿子去他幼儿园的第一个世界图书日时，他就扮成了罗宾汉。
Oh, that's fantastic. I would have had you down as a bigger fan of Robin Hood than King Arthur, because you're on the side of the yeoman, aren't you? Yeah, I think fighting with staffs over streams is very much the way I like to see myself. Yes. yes though i fear i may now i before i'm going to say it before you do um i fear now if i was cut a casting agency would see me would see me more as friar tuck but friar tuck i mean friar tuck is a dab hand with the staff isn't he he is he is of course and he's a cunning man they're all a dab hand with yeah staff the friar tuck is i i think he's quite a quite a smart fellow actually i'd happily play him so dominic you mentioned kevin costner there who apparently was meant to speak in an english accent and the director heard
哦，那太棒了。我本来会觉得你比亚瑟王更喜欢罗宾汉，因为你站在自耕农这一边，不是吗？是的，我觉得在小溪边用棍棒打斗非常符合我对自己形象的设想。是的。是的，不过我担心我现在——在你说之前我要先说——嗯，我担心如果我现在去一个选角公司，他们会把我更看作是塔克修士，但塔克修士，我是说塔克修士玩起棍棒来是一把好手，不是吗？他是的，当然是的，而且他是个精明的人，他们所有人玩棍棒都是一把好手——是的，塔克修士，我——我觉得他其实是个相当聪明的小伙子，我很乐意扮演他。所以多米尼克，你刚才提到了凯文·科斯特纳，据说他本来应该用英国口音说话，但导演听了
his accent and said no on twitter we had there's no question that kevin costner prince of thieves seems to be viewed as the worst and simultaneously the best film that's interesting it's because of canonical it's become canonical hasn't it so uh toad was was kevin costner's american robin hood the worst ever portrayal richard slade how did robin hood prince of thieves walk from dover to northumberland in one day kerry shields tips in and via hadrian's wall so the lack of geography in that yeah he comes back from the crusades and he lands at dover goes to hadrian's wall but don't you remember tom there's a bit of a bit of a theme here because we are going to skip over Russell Crowe's Robin Hood. Russell Crowe walked out of an interview with the BBC
他的口音后说不行。在推特上，毫无疑问，《盗贼王子》凯文·科斯特纳似乎被视为最烂同时也是最好的电影。这很有趣，因为它已经成为经典了，不是吗？所以，托德，凯文·科斯特纳的美版罗宾汉是有史以来最烂的塑造吗？理查德·斯莱德问：罗宾汉《盗贼王子》怎么可能在一天之内从多佛走到诺森伯兰？凯里·希尔兹回复说：是通过哈德良长城。所以那里完全没有地理概念，对吧？他从十字军东征回来，在多佛登陆，然后去了哈德良长城。但你不记得了吗，汤姆，这里有一个主线，因为我们要跳过罗塞尔·克劳的罗宾汉。罗塞尔·克劳曾气冲冲地离开一个BBC的采访，
when they challenged his accent and Mark Lawson said, there's a little bit of Irish there, there's a little bit of South Yorkshire and Russell Crowe was outraged at this because he thought he'd been doing my accent. He actually responded on Twitter as well saying that his accent had been... Russell Crowe? Yes, had been... he'd been doing my accent. He actually responded on Twitter as well, saying that his accent had been... Russell Crowe. Yes, had been... Not to us, obviously. That was a while back when the film came out.
当他们质疑他的口音时，马克·劳森说，里面有一点爱尔兰口音，有一点南约克郡口音，罗塞尔·克劳对此感到大发雷霆，因为他觉得自己模仿的是我的口音。他实际上也在推特上回应说，他的口音一直是……罗塞尔·克劳？是的，一直是……他模仿的是我的口音。他实际上也在推特上回应说，他的口音一直是……罗塞尔·克劳。是的，一直是……当然不是对我们说的。那是很久以前电影上映的时候了。
But saying that he was a Yorkshireman who'd been in the Middle East for 20 years. Right. That's what it was. It was the same attention to detail as your Liam Neeson, in other words. Exactly. It was a kind of... of yes it was a cocktail of accents um anyway the reason for mentioning uh i think uh robin hood prince of thieves yeah right at the beginning is that in many ways it is canonical i think because it reproduces all the elements of the legend that that are you know have been reproduced in children's stories and so on as to be honest
但他却说他是一个在中东待了20年的约克郡人。没错。原来是这样。换句话说，这和你的连姆·尼森有着同样的对细节的关注。没错。这是一种……是的，这是一种口音鸡尾酒。嗯，总之，提到罗宾汉《盗贼王子》的原因，我觉得就在于它在许多方面已经成为了经典，因为它重现了传说中的所有元素，这些元素（你知道的）已经在儿童故事等中被反复重现，说实话，
does the um the dis Disney film as well, in which Robin Hood is a fox and Maid Marian is literally a fox. Yeah, well, Peter Ustinov is Prince John, isn't he? Is he Prince John? Yes, he is Prince John. And Sir Hiss, Terry Thomas is Sir Hiss, who is a snake who is a psychic. Yeah, so that's an innovation. But all the sort of, I mean, we all know, I guess, Robin Hood, Maid Marian,
迪士尼的动画电影也是如此，在电影中罗宾汉是一只狐狸，玛丽安小姐字面意思就是一只狐狸。是的，皮特·乌斯蒂诺夫饰演约翰亲王，对吧？他是约翰亲王吗？是的，他就是约翰亲王。还有西斯爵士，特里·托马斯饰演西斯爵士，那是一条会催眠的蛇。对，所以这是一个创新。但所有的那些，我的意思是，我们大家都知道，我猜，罗宾汉、玛丽安小姐、
Little John, Friar Tuck, Will Scarlet, Much the Miller's Son. Alan O'Dale. Alan O'Dale, Guy of Gisborne, Prince John, obviously, the Sheriff of Nottingham, and a returning Sean Connery, or King Richard the Lionheart. In Prince of Thieves, as in lots of other ones, Robin himself is a returning crusader.
小约翰、塔克修士、威尔·斯卡利特、磨坊主的大儿子。阿兰·戴尔。阿兰·戴尔、吉斯伯恩的盖伊、约翰亲王，当然还有诺丁汉郡长，以及回归的肖恩·康纳利，也就是狮心王理查。在《盗贼王子》中，和许多其他版本一样，罗宾本人是一个归来的十字军战士。
Yes, that's right, which is a very interesting innovation in the story as we shall discover it. So the elements of the story, he robs from the rich, he gives to the poor. He rides through a glen. Yes. Sherwood Forest. Yeah. The sheriff. Yes, of course.
是的，没错，正如我们将要发现的那样，这是故事中一个非常有趣的创新。所以故事的元素包括：劫富济贫。他骑马穿过峡谷。是的。舍伍德森林。是的。郡长。是的，当然。
Archery, a lot of archery. Archery contests. Yeah. So all that stuff. Oh, and also, of course, a lot of archery. Archery contests. Yeah. So all that stuff. Oh, and also, of course, he is of noble birth. Well, that's really important that you said about being a yeoman. I mean, Robin Hood, well, we will discuss yeomanry, but in the Costner and similar versions, he is absolutely not a yeoman.
射箭，大量的射箭。射箭比赛。是的。所以所有这些东西。哦，还有，当然，他出身贵族。嗯，你刚才说他是自耕农，这一点非常重要。我是说，罗宾汉——好吧，我们会讨论自耕农阶层，但在科斯特纳和类似的版本中，他绝对不是一个自耕农。
He is nobly born, isn't he? He is. So I thought it would be interesting to look at the the oldest known ballad that mentions robin hood and go through and see what elements of it you know are being reproduced in prince of thieves and all that kind of stuff so this is robin hood and the and the monk is that the oldest uh so yeah so just to give people a sense, so these ballads are from the 15th century, aren't they? 15th century. These are the first sort of written, there are trace references to Robin Hoods in other sources, but the ballads are the real.
他出身高贵，不是吗？是的。所以我想看看现存最早的提到罗宾汉的民谣会很有趣，然后通读一遍，看看其中有哪些元素（你知道的）在《盗贼王子》和所有这些类似作品中得到了重现。所以这就是《罗宾汉与僧侣》。那是最早的……吗？所以，是的，为了让大家有个概念，这些民谣来自15世纪，对吧？15世纪。这些是最初被写下来的版本——在其他来源中也有对罗宾汉的零星提及，但民谣才是真正的核心。
Well, so the earliest mention of Robin Hood as a hero is in Piers Plowman, the great medieval alliterative poem by William Langland, from your neck of the woods Dominic? A Midlander. Yeah, a Midlander. And Robin Hood is mentioned in that and the implication is that everyone is familiar with the stories of Robin Hood.
嗯，关于罗宾汉作为英雄的最早记载是在威廉·兰格兰的中世纪宏大押韵诗《农夫皮尔斯》中，这来自你的老家多米尼克？一个米德兰人。是的，一个米德兰人。罗宾汉在那部作品中被提及，暗示了当时每个人都对罗宾汉的故事耳熟能详。
But we don't have any earlier stories than say the early 15th century so i think this is robin hood and the monk it's 1420 okay so i'll go through and tell you the plot it opens with a description of the fair forest being very merry so everything being merry yeah is there right from the absolute beginning robin hood is walking through the forest with little john so he's there right from the beginning absolutely so. So also is much the Miller's son. So he's also part of the fun.
但我们没有比15世纪初更早的故事了，所以我想这就是《罗宾汉与僧侣》，大约在1420年。好吧，我来浏览一下并给你们讲讲情节。故事开篇是对美丽的森林充满欢乐的描写，所以一切都充满欢乐——是的，从一开始就存在。罗宾汉正和小约翰一起漫步在森林里，所以他从一开始就在那里，绝对是的。还有磨坊主的大儿子。所以他也参与到了乐趣之中。
Elements that aren't there, but come in later. Robin has a deep devotion to the Virgin. He wants to go to Nottingham. So again, it's set in Nottingham. Yeah. And he wants to attend Mass and pay his devotion to the Virgin. Kevin Costner didn't do that. No, he didn't.
那些并不存在、但后来加入的元素。罗宾对圣母怀有深厚的虔诚。他想去诺丁汉。所以同样地，故事背景设在诺丁汉。是的。他想去参加弥撒，向圣母表达他的虔诚。凯文·科斯特纳可没这么做。不，他没有。
And he is absolutely, as you say, a yeoman. Little John and Robin Hood have a kind of a wager. Little John wins it. Robin refuses to pay. So Robin and Little John kind of go differently. Robin goes into Nottingham. He goes to St. Mary's Church. He's kneeling before the cross
而且他绝对如你所说，是一个自耕农。小约翰和罗宾汉打了个赌。小约翰赢了。罗宾拒绝付账。于是罗宾和小约翰分道扬镳。罗宾独自前往诺丁汉。他去了圣玛丽教堂。他跪在十字架前，
and an evil monk spots him there and rushes off and tells on him to the Sheriff of Nottingham. So the Sheriff of Nottingham is there from the beginning. Men at arms come rushing in. They capture Robin. So that's another absolute theme, isn't it?
一个邪恶的僧侣在那里发现了她，于是匆忙跑去向诺丁汉郡长告发。所以诺丁汉郡长从一开始就在场。全副武装的人冲了进来。他们抓住了罗宾。所以这是另一个绝对的主题，不是吗？
I mean, that's in the Walt Disney film. Yes. It's in the Doctor Who they're captured. He's captured with the Doctor in a story where they're fighting. The Sheriff of Nottingham is actually in league Walt Disney film. Yes. It's in the Doctor Who they're captured. He's captured with the Doctor in a story where they're fighting. The Sheriff of Nottingham is actually in league with some robots. Little John and Much the Miller, Much the Miller's son, are told, oh God, Robin's been captured. So now they have to go and rescue him.
我的意思是，沃尔特·迪士尼的电影里就有这个。是的。在《神秘博士》里他们也被抓了。他在一个与机器人战斗的故事里和博士一起被抓。诺丁汉郡长实际上与一些机器人勾结——等等，那是沃尔特·迪士尼的电影。是的。在《神秘博士》里他们也被抓了。他在一个与机器人战斗的故事里和博士一起被抓。诺丁汉郡长实际上与一些机器人勾结。小约翰和磨坊主的大儿子得知：天哪，罗宾被抓了。所以现在他们必须去营救他。
And that's another absolute. That's always happening. Standard plot. They come across the monk and the monk has a servant and is heading off to see the king to say that Robin Hood has been captured. We now have, what happens next does not tend to feature, certainly in the children's books, because what happens is, little John cuts off the monk's head.
这也是一个绝对的主题。这总是发生。标准的剧情。他们遇到了那个僧侣，僧侣带着一个仆人，正赶往国王那里去报告罗宾汉被捕的消息。接下来发生的事情，通常不会出现在儿童读物中，因为接下来发生的是：小约翰砍下了僧侣的头。
Children would love that though, I think, by and large. Just the parents who would be moaning. And much the miller cuts off the little page's head. Okay, that though i think by and large it's the parents who would who would be moaning and much the miller cuts off the little page's head okay that's harsh yes so the little boy dies as well okay little john and much the miller they they then take it's much the middle son by the way it's not much the middle son yes much the middle son sorry yes so it's actually child on child violence. Yes, exactly. They then go off and bring the news to the king. So that, I mean, we're not told who the king is,
不过孩子们大体上会很喜欢这个，我想。只有父母会抱怨。而磨坊主的大儿子砍下了小书童的头。好吧，不过孩子们大体上会很喜欢这个，我想，只有父母会抱怨。而磨坊主的大儿子砍下了小书童的头。好吧，这太残忍了，是的，所以那个小男孩也死了。好吧，小约翰和磨坊主的大儿子随后带走——顺便说一句，是磨坊主的大儿子，不是别的——是的，磨坊主的大儿子，抱歉，是的——所以实际上这是儿童对儿童的暴力。是的，完全是。他们随后出发去向国王报告这个消息。所以，我的意思是，我们并不知道国王是谁，
but the fact that, you know, the king of England is a part of this story, that again is there from the beginning. The king of England is not in the Crusades or languishing in a German prison. No, no, it's just the king. They trick the king into thinking that the monk is still alive. And so the king gives them a reward.
但事实是，英格兰国王成为了这个故事的一部分，这同样是从一开始就存在的。英格兰国王并不在十字军东征中，也没有在德国监狱里苦熬。不，不，他只是个国王。他们欺骗国王，让国王以为那个僧侣还活着。于是国王给了他们奖赏。
They then go to the sheriff of Nottingham and again, trick the sheriff of Nottingham into thinking that the monk is still alive and that they've come from the king. It's a fantastic story. It's full of wiles and tricks and scams and much merriness. The sheriff of Nottingham gives them a slap up meal with the best wine in his cellar. So they're in disguise in the heart of the castle in Nottingham so that's again absolute classic isn't it yeah and they then free robin and there it is um so it's a brilliant story yeah so there it is but i mean that's quite
然后他们去找诺丁汉郡长，再次欺骗诺丁汉郡长，让他以为僧侣还活着，而且他们是奉国王之命来的。这是一个非常棒的故事。它充满了诡计、骗局和各种欢乐。诺丁汉郡长用他地窖里最好的葡萄酒招待他们吃了一顿丰盛的大餐。所以他们伪装后潜入了诺丁汉城堡的中心，所以这又是一个绝对经典的桥段，对吧？是的，然后他们释放了罗宾，就是这样——所以这是一个精彩的故事。是的，就是这样——不过这算是个相当
a good story well the thing that's interesting in that as in these early because there are a couple of other ballads aren't there's the one's the one that I mentioned, A Jest of Robin Hood. A Jest of Robin Hood. In those stories, they are tricksters, but they're not necessarily enormously, I mean, they're not benevolent figures at all, are they? I mean, cutting pages heads off. Yeah. They are definitely outlaws. Well, so there's another guy of Gisborne.
不错的故事。嗯，有趣的是，就像这些早期故事一样——因为还有其他几首民谣，比如我提到的那首《罗宾汉的笑话》。《罗宾汉的笑话》。在这些故事里，他们是骗子，但他们并不一定是非常……我的意思是，他们根本不是什么慈善人物，对吧？我是说，把小书童的头砍下来。是的。他们绝对是流亡者。嗯，还有另一个吉斯伯恩的盖伊。
He's also right from the beginning. So that's another early of Gisborne. He's also right from the beginning. So that's another early 15th century romance. And in that, Robin cuts off Guy's head, sticks the head on the end of his bow and mutilates his face with a knife. And then there's another. So also another part of this swell, it's not just ballads. There are also plays that are being done. And one of the earliest script from a Robin Hood play comes from the Paston Letters,
他也是从一开始就在场的。所以这是另一部15世纪初的传奇故事。在那个故事里，罗宾砍下了盖伊的头，把头插在弓尖上，用刀毁了他的容。然后还有另一个。所以这也是这股风潮的另一部分——不仅仅是民谣，还有当时上演的戏剧。其中最早的罗宾汉戏剧剧本之一来自《帕斯顿书信集》，
I think we've mentioned before, this collection of letters and documents from landowners in East Anglia during the Wars of the Roses. And among all the kind of the collection of papers, there's a very short 21 line, 23 line, something like that, very short play. 23 line something like that very short play and in that robin cuts off the head and puts it in his hood so there's a lot of beheading going on yeah
我想我们以前提到过，这是《玫瑰战争》期间东盎格利亚地主们的书信和文件合集。在所有这些杂乱的文件中，有一个非常短的剧本，只有21行、23行左右，非常简短。23行左右，非常简短的戏剧。在那个剧本里，罗宾砍下了头并把它塞进了自己的兜帽里，所以里面有大量的斩首情节。是的，
but i mean people they weren't squeamish about such things and their stories were they but you mentioned the guest of robin hood that's probably the key one because that's the one with loads of elements archery contests archery contests hostility to greedy clerics because that's the one with loads of elements archery contests archery contest hostility to greedy clerics so that's you know it seems to be a running theme the king actually goes into the forest and he gets kind of kidnapped by robin and his merry men and they give him food so and then it ends with uh robin's death at the hands of his cousin the prioress of kirkley and we might come to that later on because it's a particularly fascinating aspect of the story. So all those kinds of elements are there.
但我的意思是，人们对这些事情并不感到大惊小怪，他们的故事就是这样的，不是吗？但你提到了《罗宾汉的笑话》，那可能是最关键的一本，因为里面包含了大量的元素：射箭比赛、射箭比赛、对贪婪神职人员的敌意——因为里面包含了大量的元素：射箭比赛、射箭比赛、对贪婪神职人员的敌意。所以你看，这似乎是一个贯穿始终的主题。国王甚至亲自进入森林，被罗宾和他的快乐手下们给“绑架”了，他们招待他吃东西。然后故事以罗宾死于他的表妹、柯克利修道院女修道院长之手而告终，我们可能稍后会谈到这一点，因为这是故事中一个特别迷人的方面。所以所有这些元素都在里面。
But I think elements that are not there. Yeah, let's talk, because they're really interesting about the point at which they come in. I think that's fascinating. Elements that are not there. Robbing from the rich to give to the poor. Yeah. That is not really an rich to give to the poor.
但我觉得有些元素并不存在。是的，我们来聊聊这个，因为它们加入的时机非常有趣。我觉得这太迷人了。那些不存在的元素。劫富济贫。是的。那并不是一个
Yeah. That is not really an element in any of the surviving kind of medieval Tudor. Well, do you know what? Do you know what I read about this? There was a historian called J.C. Holt. He was very keen on cricket, apparently, Tom, so should appeal to you. He wrote a book about Robin Hood in the 1980s. And he suggests in one of his articles about Robin Hood that these plays that you mentioned were put on by sort of ecclesiastical authorities
劫富济贫的元素。是的。那其实并不是任何现存的中世纪都铎时期作品中的元素。你知道吗？你知道我关于这个读到了什么吗？有一位历史学家叫J·C·霍特。据说他非常喜欢板球，汤姆，所以这应该会吸引你。他在20世纪80年代写过一本关于罗宾汉的书。他在其中一篇关于罗宾汉的文章中暗示，你刚才提到的那些戏剧是由某种教会当局在
in the 16th century. And they would have, at the end, the people playing Robin and the other characters would have collections for the church. And often it was really sort of impressed upon you that you had to give. It was a lot of pressure. And that all this sort of stuff about taking from the rich and giving to the poor, there's a sort of hint that it was basically a massive wheeze to get to force, make people feel guilty and make them give money
16世纪上演的。在表演结束时，扮演罗宾和其他角色的演员们会为教会进行募捐。通常那种情况真的会给你留下深刻印象，逼着你必须捐钱。那是一种很大的压力。所有关于劫富济贫的种种说法，其实都有一种暗示，即这基本上是一个巨大的骗局，目的是强迫、让人产生负罪感，让他们在演出结束后把钱捐给
to the church at the end of the performance. Yeah i think it's going with the grain of the stories so um the end of the guest uh it it said that robin did um he did poor men much good so it's not saying he's taken from the rich to give to the poor but he you know he's known as a friend of the poor he's known as a friend of women yeah um he he there's that sense of a kind of chivalry there um And there's a story in which in the guest, there is a poor knight who is down on his uppers, who's being kind of screwed out of his money by an evil band of monks in a monastery. And Robin comes to his rescue.
教会。是的，我觉得这符合故事的基调。所以在《笑话》的结尾，据说罗宾为穷人做了很多好事。所以它并没有说他是劫富济贫，而是说（你知道的）他是穷人的朋友，他是女性的朋友。是的，那里有一种骑士精神的感觉。
Robin from the rich to give to the distressed middle classes is not really. That's effectively what that story is. Yeah. Well, the same historian, J.C. Holt, we had a lot of questions saying, is Robin a proto-socialist? Richard Brabner said, is he a precursor to socialism or paternalistic Toryism? And I would say at first, the latter.
在《笑话》里有一个故事，讲的是一个穷困潦倒的骑士，他的钱被修道院里的一帮邪恶僧侣榨干了。罗宾前来施以援手。劫富济救济中产阶级其实并不是……这实际上就是那个故事演出来的效果。是的。好吧，同一位历史学家J·C·霍特——我们收到了很多问题，问：罗宾是原始社会主义者吗？理查德·布拉布纳问：他是社会主义的先驱还是家长式托利主义者？而我会首先说，是后者。
I mean, obviously, they're ridiculously sort of anachronistic concepts to be imposing on this because I don't i don't think i don't get a sense from those early ballads or the early plays particularly if they're being licensed by church authorities and used to drum up enthusiasm in collections i don't get a sense that they're terribly subversive do you tom do you think these are undermining the social order or are they having fun i mean that they go out of their way, even though Robin and his mates are cutting Paige's heads off. They're still, the ballads tell you that they're very courteous, don't they? I mean, that one that I read out at the beginning of the show said,
我的意思是，很显然，把这些概念强加在这些作品上是极其不合时宜的，因为我不认为——我从那些早期的民谣或早期戏剧中感觉不到——特别是如果它们是由教会当局授权并用来在募捐中煽动热情的话——我不认为它们有多大的颠覆性，对吧，汤姆？你认为这些是在破坏社会秩序，还是大家只是在图个乐子？我的意思是，尽管罗宾和他的同伴们在砍小书童的头，但他们依然——民谣告诉你他们非常有礼貌，对吧？我的意思是，我在节目开头读的那首民谣说，
you know, as courteous a man you'll never find, or whatever words to that effect. So they're not threatening, are they? Well, there's a book came out a couple of years ago, Story Worlds of Robin Hood by Leslie Coote, who's kind of one of the great living experts on Robin Hood. not threatening are they well this book came out a couple of years ago uh story worlds of robin hood um by leslie coote who's kind of one of the great living experts on robin hood and she has an excellent theory about where robin hood comes from but i think we should save looking at that for the second half because i think the second half we should look at where do these stories
（你知道的）你永远找不到比他更有礼貌的人，或者大意如此的话。所以他们并不具有威胁性，对吧？嗯，几年前出过一本书，叫《罗宾汉的故事世界》，作者是莱斯利·库特，她是罗宾汉研究领域的伟大在世专家之一。不具有威胁性，对吧？嗯，几年前出过一本书，叫《罗宾汉的故事世界》，作者是莱斯利·库特，她是罗宾汉研究领域的伟大在世专家之一。关于罗宾汉的起源，她有一个极好的理论，但我觉得我们应该把这部分留到下半场再看，因为我觉得在下半场我们应该探讨这些故事到底源自何方，
where where might these stories come from you know might there be a real robin hood and if not then where would the stories come from? I hope you'll say that there is a real Robin Hood. Well, you have to wait and see. You'll have to wait and see. But there were a couple of elements that we haven't got onto. So the robbing from the rich to give to the poor, okay, we've done. What about Maid Marian?
这些故事可能从何而来（你知道的），到底有没有一个真实的罗宾汉？如果没有，那这些故事又是从哪里来的？我希望你会说真的存在一个罗宾汉。好吧，你得拭目以待。你得拭目以待。不过还有几个我们还没涉及到的元素。所以，劫富济贫，好吧，我们说过了。那玛丽安小姐呢？
Where's Maid Marian come from? Let's park her for now. Maid Marian is a part of the kind of the mayday rituals that you get in the 16th century she's not necessarily associated with robin hood she's french isn't she there's an implication that that she belongs to a kind of different series of stories uh the made marion that we get you know as in films now i mean it's basically a 19th century invention yeah um so i think in the 17th century robin has a wife called clarinda which which is not something that's no it doesn't trip off the tongue so uh but another you know really fascinating example of perhaps of um the way that uh folk
玛丽安小姐是从哪儿来的？我们先把她放一边。玛丽安小姐是16世纪五朔节传统仪式的一部分，她一开始并不一定与罗宾汉联系在一起。她是法国人，对吧？这里有一种暗示，即她属于一系列完全不同的故事。我们现在在电影中看到的玛丽安小姐（你知道的）——我的意思是，这基本上是19世纪的发明。是的。所以我想在17世纪，罗宾有一个妻子叫克琳达，这并不是一个——这并不顺口，所以……但另一个（你知道的）关于英国民间故事运作方式的真正迷人的例子，当然就是他——因为罗宾是一个非常具有向上流动性的人物。所以我们谈到他是如何成为一个自耕农，然后最终成为贵族成员的——洛克斯利的罗伯特或洛克斯利的罗伯特，诸如此类。是的。
stories work in britain is of course he because robin is a very upwardly mobile figure so we talked about how he's a yeoman and he ends up as a you know a member of the aristocracy robert of loxley or robert of loxley all that yeah um and this is um this seems to be an invention of a a tudor playwright called anthony monday who in the 1590s writes two apparently not very good plays i haven't read them oh yes the downfall of robert earl of huntingdon is that the play Anthony Munday, who in the 1590s writes two apparently not very good plays. I haven't read them. Oh, yes. The Downfall of Robert Earl of Huntingdon.
这似乎是16世纪90年代一个名叫安东尼·芒迪的都铎剧作家发明的。他在1590年代写了两部显然不太好的戏剧——我没读过。哦，是的，《罗伯特·亨廷顿伯爵的衰落》，那是那部戏剧吗？安东尼·芒迪在1590年代写了两部显然不太好的戏剧。我没读过。哦，是的，《罗伯特·亨廷顿伯爵的衰落》。
Is that the play? And The Death. I haven't seen it. And The Death of Robert Earl of Huntingdon. Oh, right. And there's also a late 16th century biography, which identifies him as coming from Loxley. And that then gets picked up by Sir Walter Scott in the beginning of the 19th century in ivanhoe which is probably you know the key fictional work that helps to to
是那部剧吗？还有《死亡》。我没看过。《罗伯特·亨廷顿伯爵的死亡》。哦，对了。还有一部16世纪末的传记，指出他来自洛克斯利。这随后在19世纪初被沃尔特·斯科特爵士在《艾凡赫》中采用，这可能就是（你知道的）那个帮助生成这一神话的关键虚构作品。
generate the myth and so this idea that robert is not actually a yeoman but that he is a dispossessed nobleman that he is earl of huntingdon or locksley or whatever. It seems to be something that gradually evolves over the course of... But to go back to the point where that comes in, so late 16th century. So the myth or the legend, the stories have been circulating, we know, for at least 150, 200 years, probably longer, probably much longer. There doesn't seem to be an obvious kind of ideological subtext to making him an aristocrat at this particular moment in time. It's just a riff on the story, isn't it? I mean, there's no reason for somebody in Elizabethan England to
因此，罗宾其实不是自耕农，而是一个被剥夺财产的贵族，他是亨廷顿伯爵或洛克斯利等等的这种观点，似乎是在这个过程中逐渐演变出来的……但回到这个概念出现的节点来看，那就是16世纪末。所以这个神话或传说、这些故事我们知道已经流传了至少150、200年，可能更久，可能远不止于此。在历史上的这个特定时刻，把他变成一个贵族并没有什么显而易见的意识形态暗流。这只是对故事的一种演绎，对吧？我的意思是，伊丽莎白时代的某个人没有任何理由去
think, oh, we need an aristocratic hero rather than a yeoman. Don't you think, Tom? One of the things is interesting uh about the ballads the early the kind of medieval ones is that there's no reason it's given why robin is an outlaw uh and in fact there's a question from josh wilcox on the discord why was robin an outlaw we're never told um in the early ballads the first person to mention why robin might be an outlaw is actually not English, but Scottish. So there's a whole series of, weirdly, of historians in Scotland,
想：哦，我们需要一个贵族英雄而不是一个自耕农。你不这么觉得吗，汤姆？关于这些民谣（早期的那种中世纪民谣），有趣的事情之一就是，故事中没有给出任何理由来解释为什么罗宾会成为一个流亡者。事实上，Discord上乔什·威尔科克斯提出了一个问题：为什么罗宾会成为流亡者？我们从来不知道。在早期的民谣中，第一个提及罗宾为什么会成为流亡者的人其实不是英国人，而是苏格兰人。所以奇怪的是，苏格兰有一连串的历史学家，
again, writing in the 15th century. Well, they're the first non-fiction references. Yeah, so they're referring to him as a kind of historical figure. Yeah. And one of them, he's writing a kind of mid-15th century, a guy called Walter Bauer,
同样是在15世纪写作。好吧，那是第一批非虚构记载。是的，所以他们把他当作一个历史人物来提及。是的。其中一个人在15世纪中期左右写作，一个叫沃尔特·鲍尔的人，
posits the idea that Robin had been fighting with Simon de Montfort against the armies of Henry III and Prince Edward, who will go on to become Edward I. And that you have the Battle of Evesham in which Simon de Montfort is killed and, of course, brutally gelded, his corpse is mutilated. And Walter B and um Walter Bower says well maybe Robin was uh you know he was fighting there and he had to then flee into the uh into into the woods and that's then followed up by another Scott um writing at the beginning of the 16th century a guy called John Mayer or John Major oh yeah John Major my friend John Major um who uh he is the first to suggest that Robin had lived in the time of Richard I, Richard the Lionheart. And he is the one who kind of casts him as, again, of being an overtly
提出了这样一个观点：罗宾曾与西蒙·德·蒙福特并肩作战，对抗亨利三世和后来成为爱德华一世的爱因斯坦（应为爱德华王子）的军队。然后发生了伊夫舍姆战役，西蒙·德·蒙福特在战役中被杀，当然，他的尸体也被残忍地阉割和肢解。沃尔特·鲍……沃尔特·鲍尔说，好吧，也许罗宾当时也在那里战斗，然后他不得不逃进树林里。这个说法随后被另一位在16世纪初写作的苏格兰人、一个叫约翰·梅尔或约翰·迈杰尔的人所采纳——哦，是的，约翰·迈杰尔，我的朋友约翰·迈杰尔——他……他是第一个提出罗宾生活在理查一世（狮心王理查）时代的人。而且他是那个再次将罗宾塑造成一个公开的贵族形象的人。
aristocratic figure. And so I think there you get the kind of the germ of the idea that Robin has become an outlaw because he is facing evil times, but he is on the side of the king. Because if you're trying to, in a way, make Robin safe, to make him someone that decent people can identify with, you have to give him a reason for being an outlaw that isn't to do with, you know, chopping off people's heads or mutilating them with knives or whatever. And so the idea that he is a nobleman
所以我觉得，在这里你可以看到这样一种观念的萌芽：罗宾之所以成为流亡者，是因为他面临着黑暗的时代，但他站在国王这一边。因为如果你想以某种方式让罗宾变得“安全”，让他成为一个正直的人能够认同的角色，你必须给他一个成为流亡者的理由，这个理由不能与砍人脑袋或用刀毁容之类的事情有关。因此，他是一个遭到邪恶的约翰亲王等人不公正迫害的贵族的观点——我的意思是，这太理想了。这绝对是理想的，因为他站在国王这一边，而且他也有留在绿林之中的正当理由。但这显然是后来才出现的，对吧？因为所有20世纪或19世纪对罗宾汉的演绎中，他都是一个好小伙，他是一个（正如你所说）他不是个罪犯。但这些早期关于罗宾汉的记载——我的意思是，他们通常谈论的是一个被普遍视为罪犯的人，
who has been unjustly persecuted by bad Prince John or something like that, I mean, that's ideal. That's absolutely ideal because he's on the side of the king, but he also has a legitimate reason to be out in the Greenwood. But that obviously comes in later on, doesn't it? Because all the 20th century iterations or 19th century of robin hood he's a he's a nice fellow he's a you know he's as you say he's not a criminal but these early mentions of robin hood i mean they're generally talking about somebody who's perceived very much as a criminal aren't
不是吗？所以那些早期的民谣属于漫长的民谣传统，这些民谣实际上有点微弱地赞美了那种智胜当局的骗子形象。但在这些民谣中，没有任何迹象表明他是被冤枉的，对吧？他完全……没有任何理由解释他为什么会在森林里。是的。根本没有给出任何解释。但也许根本不需要——我的意思是，也许人们根本不需要解释，因为尤其是当他们已经对这个人物熟悉的情况下——如果他在民间记忆中已经占据了一席之地，所以每个人都知道罗宾汉仅仅是一个流亡者。难道没有这样一种说法吗：在这一时期，成为一个“罗宾汉”，
they so those early ballads are in the long tradition of ballads that actually slightly sort of celebrate the kind of trickster figure, outwitting the authorities. But there's no sort of, I mean, there's no sense in those ballads that he's been unjustly accused, is there? He simply, there is no explanation given for why he's in the forest. Yeah. No explanation is given at all. But maybe there's no, I mean, maybe people wouldn't have needed an explanation well because especially if they're already familiar with the figure of if he has a kind of place in the folk memory already so everybody knows that robin hood is is merely an outlaw and isn't there some suggestion that to be a robin hood in this sort of period
这是一种赋予那些……你只是一个“罗宾汉”的通用名字？是的，所以这都是可能融入传说的各种影响的漩涡的一部分，我觉得我们应该在下半场来看看这些。但审视故事从16世纪开始的演变方式，是的，我觉得很明显，罗宾为什么在森林里的那种感觉已经丢失了，或者人们觉得需要对他在那里的原因做出某种解释。而符合公众接受观点的一种解释是：他站在正义的国王一边。他是反抗不公正压迫的叛逆者。他很可能有着贵族背景。这就是为什么把他设定在狮心王理查统治时期、由糟糕的约翰亲王担任摄政王的构想会如此契合的原因。
that this is that this is a kind of generic name that is given to people who are you're just a robin hood yeah so this is all part of the swirl of of possible influences that might feed into the legend and i think we should look at them in the in the second half but looking at the way that the story evolves from the 16th century onwards yeah i think it's it's clear that a sense of why Robin is in the forest has been lost, or there is a feeling that some explanation needs to be provided as to why he's there. And the one that goes with the grain of acceptable opinion is that he's on the side of the rightful king. He is a rebel against unjust oppression. He's probably of aristocratic background. And that's why the idea of him as someone in the reign of Richard the Lionheart with bad Prince John as the regent.
这就是为什么它如此完美地契合，因为它提供了绝对完美的背景。所以在17世纪左右——我的意思是，莎士比亚提到了罗宾汉，不是吗？是的，《维罗纳二绅士》里也有，我想。但这只是一种随意的提及，哦，绿林好汉罗宾。这些都只是顺便提及，对吧？但随后他似乎就沉寂了，不是吗，罗宾汉？
That's why it kind of it suits it perfectly because it provides the absolutely kind of perfect context. So by, let's say, the 17th century, I mean, so Shakespeare mentions Robin Hood, doesn't he? Yeah, and you like it. And Two Gentlemen of Verona as well, I think. But that's just a sort of reference to, oh, Robin in the Greenwood. They're kind of passing references, aren't they? But then there's a, he sort of goes quiet, doesn't he, Robin Hood,
在17、18世纪，你会这么说吗？嗯，到了18世纪末，出现了一个叫约瑟夫·里森的人。现在，我觉得他是一个非常有趣的人。是的。他非常讨厌罗宾可能具有贵族背景这种观点。因为约瑟夫·里森的政治立场非常左翼。他是法国大革命的狂热爱好者，诸如此类。汤姆，我是不是该跟你讲点关于约瑟夫·里森的事？
in the 17th, 18th century, would you say? Well, you have this, at the end of the 18th century, you have this guy called Joseph Ritson. Now, he's a very interesting man, I think. Yes. So he's very annoyed by the idea that Robin might be of an aristocratic background. Because Joseph Ritson is very much on the left. He's a great enthusiast for the French Revolution, all that kind of stuff he's also tom should i tell you something about joseph ritson yeah tell me um he has something in common with you or
好的，讲吧。嗯，他身上有一些和你相似的地方，或者你曾经浅尝辄止的东西。你想猜猜吗？呃，不，我想不出来。你曾有一段时间在家庭压力下尝试过素食主义。你现在已经正式放弃了吗？基本上，我是个素食主义者。好吧。所以他和你一样是个素食者，但他似乎主要靠吃玛芬蛋糕和糕点度日。是吗？
something that you flirted with do you want to guess uh no i can't think so you had a period where you flirted with vegetarianism under domestic pressure. Have you formally abandoned that? Basically, I'm vegetarian. Okay. So he, like you, was vegetarian, but he largely seemed to eat muffins and cakes. Did he?
蘸着甜甜圈吃。你知道后来怎么了吗？他疯了。他在疯人院里度过了余生。我还以为你会说他变得胖得离谱。好吧，也许他也那样了，我不知道。不过是的，他是法国大革命的狂热崇拜者。所以他第一次把所有的民谣收集在了一起。
Dunking donuts. And do you know what happened? He went mad. He ended his days in a lunatic style. I thought you were going to say he got enormously fat. Well, maybe he did that too. I don't know. But yes, he was a great enthusiast for the French Revolution. So he brings together all the ballads for the first time.
但他显然也认为罗宾汉是真实存在的。是的。他把罗宾汉视为某种准雅各宾党人，不是吗？是的。所以他把罗宾汉颂扬为一个颠覆者、一个激进分子。是的。绝对是劫富济贫。然后奇怪的是，沃尔特·斯科特，
But he also clearly thinks that Robin Hood was real. Yeah. And he sees him as a sort of proto-Jacobin, doesn't he? Yeah. So he celebrates him as a subversive, as a radical. Yeah. Absolutely robbing from the rich to give to the poor. And then the weird thing is that Walter Scott,
他绝对不是什么颠覆分子或激进分子，但他基本上是约瑟夫·里森唯一的朋克朋友（应为朋友）。也许是因为里森总是给别人端上玛芬蛋糕吧，我不知道。哦，不，又是玛芬蛋糕。不管怎样，沃尔特·斯科特显然从他的朋友里森那里获得了一些创作《艾凡赫》的灵感，取材于罗宾汉的故事？
who absolutely is not a subversive or a radical, he's basically Joseph Ritson's only friend. Maybe because Ritson keeps serving muffins to other people. I don't know. Oh, no, not muffins again. Anyway, Walter Scott apparently gets some of the ideas for Ivanhoe from his friends, from the Robin Hood story in Ritson?
我的意思是，你可以看出里森收集了所有这些民谣（你知道的），这对他那个时代的所有诗人和小说家都产生了巨大的影响。所以《艾凡赫》就是一部经典之作。它其中著名的一幕不仅引入了射箭比赛，还有把箭射成两半的绝技。箭射中了靶心，然后罗宾走上前去，把那支已经射中靶心的箭一劈为二。所以这是神话中非常著名的一部分。但沃尔特·斯科特引入的另一个著名的东西是盎格鲁-撒克逊人和诺曼人之间存在敌对关系的观念。
I mean, I think you can see that Ritson's collect, you know, he assembles all these ballads and it has a huge influence on all the kind of poets and novelists of the time. So Ivanhoe is the classic one. And that brings in famously, not just an archery contest, but splitting the arrow. The arrow hits the middle of the bull, and then Robin steps forward and splits the arrow that's hit the bull. So that's a famous part of the myth. But the other famous thing that Walter Scott introduces is the idea of a rivalry between Anglo-Saxons and Normans.
是的。是的。所以我想我们对此有一个问题。是的。所以，克劳福特，作为本节目的忠实听众，问：这个传说中有多少、现实中有多少是以盎格鲁-撒克逊人反抗诺曼枷锁的概念为中心的？这在任何中世纪文献中都根本不存在。
Yes. Yeah. So I think we have a question on that. Yeah. So Crowfoot, very much a friend of the show, how much of the legend and how much of the reality centred around the notion of the Anglo-Saxons rebelling against the Norman yoke, that is not in any way a part of any medieval. No, because surely the medieval 15th century, or indeed a couple of centuries earlier, they would have, I mean, that's just ancient history to them, isn't it?
是的，我的意思是，他们根本没有那种意识。不，当然没有。但这对于苏格兰人来说非常重要。嗯，因为人们重新发现了盎格鲁-撒克逊人的概念，部分是因为诺曼枷锁——是的，他们显然是在17世纪之后的余波中写作的，每个人都在乎诺曼枷锁。嗯，而且——我记得我大概在12或13岁左右读过《艾凡赫》，我发现关于撒克逊人和诺曼人的那些内容非常有说服力。
Yeah, I mean, they don't have a sense of that at all. No, of course not. But it's very important to Scots. Well, because people have rediscovered the idea of the anglo-saxons partly because of the norman yoke yeah they're obviously writing in the aftermath yeah of the 17th century and everybody cared about the norman yoke and um and that's i mean i remember reading ivanhoe when i was i don't know 12 or 13 or something and i found that stuff about saxons and normans, immensely persuasive.
而且，它也出现在埃罗尔·弗林的《罗宾汉》中。是的，确实如此。你知道那句名言吗：我痛恨的不公正，而不是诺曼人。还有另一个，就在浪漫主义时期——也就是里森的发现之后沃尔特·斯科特的那个时期——另一个对后世产生深远影响的重大创新是一本关于玛丽安小姐的小说，作者是托马斯·洛夫·皮科克，他是雪莱的朋友，写过一些讽刺小说，如果你了解那个时代的话其实还挺搞笑的，但除此之外——我的意思是，完全看不懂。所以他关于罗宾汉的小说很难读，因为它充满了关于那些谁都没听说过的政客的内部笑话。但他引入了罗宾汉和诺丁汉郡长之间三角恋的概念。
Well, it's also, I mean, it's in the Errol Flynn Robin Hood. Yes, it is. You know, the famous line, it's not injustice, it's injustice I hate, not the Normans. But also the other, just in the kind of, say, the romantic period, the period of Walter Scott in the aftermath of Ritson's discoveries, The other big innovation that has a kind of momentous afterlife is a novel about Maid Marian written by Thomas Love Peacock, who was a friend of Shelley's and wrote satirical novels that are actually quite funny if you know about the period, but otherwise, I mean, absolutely nothing. So his novel about Robin Hood is quite hard to read because it's full of kind of in-jokes about politicians that nobody's heard of. But he introduces the idea of the love triangle between Robin Hood, Sheriff of Nottingham.
哦，诺丁汉郡长卷入了一场三角恋，哦，因为他当然想结婚。这只有在诺丁汉郡长想要玛丽安的财富的意义上才算是一场三角恋，不是吗？20世纪通常不都是这么说的吗？说她是个女继承人什么的？是的，通常都是这么设定的。也许我只是想到了艾伦·里克曼那种俯视玛丽·伊丽莎白·马斯特兰托尼奥的眼神，对吧？没、错、是的。
Oh, the Sheriff of Nottingham is involved in a love triangle with, oh, because of course he wants to marry. It's only a love triangle in the sense that the Sheriff of Nottingham wants Marion's money, isn't he? Isn't that the usual claim in the 20th century? That she's an heiress or something? Yes, that's usually how it's factored in. Maybe I'm just thinking of Alan Rickman kind of looking after Mary Elizabeth Mastrantonio, was it? That's right, yes.
威胁着用勺子挖出别人的心。你知道，据说那部电影不得不重新剪辑，导演也被从剪辑师名单中除名，因为艾伦·里克曼太抢眼了，他威胁到了凯文·科斯特纳的 ego（自我）。你知道，据说那部电影不得不重新剪辑，导演也被从剪辑师名单中除名，因为艾伦·里克曼太抢眼了，他威胁到了凯文·科斯特纳的 ego。是的。嗯，就好像他演的是一部完全不同的电影，不是吗？
Threatening to open up people's hearts with spoons. You know, apparently that film had to be re-edited and the director was removed from the edit because Alan Rickman was too prominent and he was threatening Kevin Costner's ego. You know, apparently that film had to be re-edited and the director was removed from the edit because Alan Rickman was too prominent and he was threatening Kevin Costner's ego. Yes. Well, it's like he's in a completely different film, isn't it?
是的，确实如此。他在里面的表现太精彩了。我记得那是那种跃然荧幕之上的表演之一。总之，我们别再讨论艾伦·里克曼了，多聊聊罗宾汉的历史吧。所以，玛丽安小姐在维多利亚时代早期确实已经进入了故事。而且你还有——我的意思是，还有一个我们还没怎么深入探讨的角色。
Yeah, it is. He's brilliant in it. I remember it was one of those performances that just kind of left off the screen. Anyway, we should stop talking about Alan Rickman and talk more about the history of Robin Hood. So, Mary Marion has definitely entered the story by the early Victorian period. And you've also got, I mean, one other character we haven't massively talked about,
是的，确实如此。他在里面的表现太精彩了。我记得那是那种仿佛能跃然屏幕之上的表演之一。不管怎样，我们该停止谈论阿伦·瑞克曼，多聊聊罗宾汉的历史了。玛丽安夫人确实在维多利亚时代早期就进入了这个故事。而且你还提到过，我是说，还有一个我们没有怎么谈论的角色，
Friar Tuck has also entered the story. And he's a real person, isn't he, Friar Tuck? Yeah. So he's there from the beginning. But he seems to, he was a priest from Sussex, I think, who was around in the early 15th century. And then he enters the story. Yes. He comes in in 1475.
小 Friar Tuck（塔克修士）也出场了。他也是个真人，对吧，塔克修士？对。所以他从一开始就在。不过他似乎——我记得他是个萨塞克斯郡的牧师，生活在15世纪初。然后他进入了故事中。是的。他是在1475年登场的。
But he had – he's called Robert Stafford. And he gathered around him, it says in the, it says J.C. Holt, a band of evildoers who committed murders and robberies and threatened the peace of Surrey and Sussex. So he's very much a, he's a Surrey and Sussex man. He's not a Yorkshireman or a man of Nottinghamshire. But he just gets kind of woven into the story. But as Friar Tuck, he's disguised as Friar Tuck. And then, interestingly, he must have been quite a malevolent figure at first if he's a real-life criminal.
但他的名字——他叫罗伯特·斯塔福德（Robert Stafford）。根据资料记载，J.C.霍尔特（J.C. Holt）说，他身边聚集了一帮作恶多端的人，他们杀人越货、打劫行抢，威胁着萨里郡和萨塞克斯郡的和平。所以他很大程度上是个萨里和萨塞克斯人。他不是约克郡人，也不是诺丁汉郡人。但他只是被编入了故事中。不过化身为塔克修士时，他是伪装成塔克修士的。然后，有趣的是，如果他是个现实生活中的罪犯，那他最初一定是个相当心肠歹毒的人物。
But obviously, certainly by the 20th century, Friar Tuck is comic relief, really, isn't he? Well, but also, of course, if he gets back projected to the time of Richard the Lionheart, there were no friars at that point. Were there not? Why were there no friars? Because, you know, it's before...
但很显然，至少到了20世纪，塔克修士基本上成了喜剧调剂的角色，不是吗？嗯，不过当然，如果把他反向投射到狮心王理查的时代，那个时期其实根本没有修士。难道没有吗？为什么没有修士？因为，你知道的，这在那之前……
Friaring was invented. Before St. Francis. I don't know anything about friars, Tom. To be honest with you, I know you'll say that you found this absolutely a shameful moment in the history of the podcast. I don't really know the difference between a monk and a friar. Well, a friar is itinerant. Okay.
修士制度被发明出来之前。在圣方济各之前。我对修士一无所知，汤姆。老实说，我知道你会说你觉得这是播客历史上绝对耻辱的一个时刻。我其实分不清僧侣和修士的区别。嗯，修士是四处游历的。好吧。
Monks are generally monasteries okay well they now i know now yeah so so um the friars who are itinerant become robin's allies yeah the monks who are resident greedy a greedy kind of yeah that so that's how that's how it works basically by the beginning of the 19th century i think you've got all the elements in place yeah and there's one more sort of iteration isn't it that's really important which is so actually all the what's really interesting all these stories up to this point they're never for children i mean children might enjoy them but they but they're not written for children and then there's an american writer who i think is i mean he's not as well known as walter scott but arguably equally as important certainly in the
僧侣通常待在修道院里。好吧，我现在知道了。所以，嗯，那些四处游历的修士成了罗宾的盟友；嗯，那些长驻的僧侣则贪婪成性，就是那种……所以事情基本上就是这样。到19世纪初，我觉得所有的元素都已经凑齐了。而且还有一个更重要的演变，不是吗？实际上，真正有趣的是，所有这些直到这个时期的故事，从来都不是为儿童写的——我的意思是儿童可能会喜欢它们，但它们不是为儿童写的。然后出现了一位美国作家，我认为他——我的意思是，他的名气不如沃尔特·斯科特（Walter Scott），但可以说同样重要，尤其是在...
transition to america into cinema who is a guy called Howard Pyle. So I think we actually have some of Howard Pyle's children's books in our house because they're still being, they've never been out of print. And his version of, he's a man from Delaware. And his version of Robin Hood, he published in 1883 when he was 30. And he did the illustrations himself. So he also, interestingly, he also created the – he's a very influential illustrator because he created the illustrations for pirate stories that established the template for a pirate. So – and he does these beautiful illustrations.
向美国和电影界的过渡中，这个人名叫霍华德·派尔（Howard Pyle）。所以我想我们家里其实有一些霍华德·派尔的儿童书，因为它们一直在出版，从未绝版。他版本的——他是德拉瓦州人。他出版于1883年他30岁时罗宾汉的版本，插图都是他自己画的。所以很有意思的是，他也创作了——他是一位极具影响力的插画家，因为他为海盗故事创作的插图确立了海盗的模板。所以——而且他画了这些精美的插图。
You know, Robin is in kind of Lincoln Green or whatever. And the feather in the hat. The feathers in the hat. All of this sort of stuff he also invents the dialect that is the kind of faux medieval dialect so thou wilts you know all this sort of stuff yeah but also there's an enormous amount of merriness isn't there yeah merrily inordinately merry and philanthropy that it's just kind of larks it's yeah they're going around having romps nobody ever has their head cut off in these stories.
你知道的，罗宾穿着林肯绿或者别的什么衣服，帽子上还插着羽毛。帽子上的羽毛。所有这些乱七八糟的东西也是他发明的，还有那种虚假的、中世纪风格的方言，比如“thou wilts”之类的。但同时，里面也有大量的高兴劲儿，不是吗？是的，极其快乐的快乐，还有行善，就像是一场闹剧，是的，他们四处游玩嬉戏，这些故事里从来没有人被砍头。
There's no mutilations or anything like that. And I think the success of Howard Pyle's version, so the tremendous success that had, I guess, with children in the 1880s, 1890s, probably explains why Hollywood come to... Absolutely it does. Because without Pyle, Robin would not have the resonance in the US.
没有肢体残缺之类的事情。我想霍华德·派尔这个版本的成功，在1880年代、1890年代的儿童中取得的巨大成功，大概解释了为什么好莱坞会……绝对是的。因为如果没有派尔，罗宾汉在美国就不会有这么大的共鸣。
No. So we talked in our 1922 podcast about Douglas Fairbanks' silent version of Robin Hood that later inspires Errol Flynn's version. In Douglas Fairbanks' version, that's the first film to have a Hollywood premiere. And I think both that and the um errol flynn version enormously successful very big budget you know robin hood is a hot hot intellectual kind of commercial property in early 20th century america and then one final twist on that theme is that the adventures of robin hood which becomes a kind of massive TV series in Britain and features Sid James.
没有。所以在我们1922年的播客中，我们谈到了道格拉斯·范克斯（Douglas Fairbanks）无声版的《罗宾汉》，这后来启发了埃罗尔·弗林（Errol Flynn）的版本。在道格拉斯·范克斯的版本中，那是第一部举行好莱坞首映的电影。而且我认为无论是那个版本还是埃罗尔·弗林的版本，都取得了巨大的成功、拥有非常高的预算。你知道的，罗宾汉是20世纪初美国一个炙手可热的、具有商业价值的IP。接着，这个主题的一个最终转折是，《罗宾汉历险记》（The Adventures of Robin Hood）在英国成为了一部火爆的电视剧，由西德·詹姆斯（Sid James）主演。
Sid James was in it. Leslie Phillips was in it. Jane Asher was in it. Steptoe and some, you know, Wilfred Bramble and that thingy. They were, they were absolutely chock-a-block full of British character actors.
西德·詹姆斯参演了。莱斯利·菲利普斯（Leslie Phillips）参演了。简·阿什尔（Jane Asher）参演了。还有《斯特普托父子》（Steptoe and Son）里的威尔弗雷德·布拉姆贝尔（Wilfred Bramble）和那个谁。里面全都是英国的性格演员。
But, but the script for that was written by Americans who had fled the US because they were victims of McCarthyism. Of course it was, yes. And in fact, there's at least one school district in America where there was talk of banning stories of Robin Hood because they were seen as too communist, robbing from the rich and giving to the poor.
但是，剧本是由一些美国人写的，他们因为是麦卡锡主义的受害者而逃离了美国。当然是的。事实上，美国至少有一个学区曾讨论过要禁掉罗宾汉的故事，因为它们被视为太共产主义了——劫富济贫嘛。
Should we sing the song to see us out? I think you can sing it. So I think that... Because I've done my ballad for today, Tom. I think that we should end on this note. And then when we come back, we should ask the question, did Robin Hood really exist? The real Robin Hood.
我们应该唱首歌来作为结束吗？我觉得你可以唱。所以我觉得……因为我已经唱完我今天的民谣了，汤姆。我觉得我们应该以此结束。然后等我们回来后，我们应该提出一个问题：罗宾汉真的存在过吗？真正的罗宾汉。
Or where does the story come from? The mystery is solved at last. We're very good at solving mysteries. What was the last mystery we solved? The Princess and the Tower? The Princess and the Tower, wasn't it? Yeah, it was. So go on, sing a song, Tom.
或者这个故事是从哪里来的？谜团终于解开了。我们很擅长解开谜团。我们上一次解开的谜团是什么？《公主与高塔》（The Princess and the Tower）？是《公主与高塔》，对吧？是的，确实是。所以，快唱首歌吧，汤姆。
Okay. Robin Hood, Robin Hood, riding through the glen. Robin Hood, Robin Hood, with his band of men. Robs from the rich, gives to the poor. No, it's not that, is it? It's feared by the bad. No, what is it? Feared by the bad.
好吧。罗宾汉，罗宾汉，穿行于林谷间。罗宾汉，罗宾汉，带着他的好汉团。劫富，济贫。不对，不是这样的，对吧？坏人的克星。不对，是什么来着？坏人的克星。
Loved by the good. Robin Hood, Robin Hood. Robin Hood. That started too well, and I thought it wasn't going to be funny. But then when it degenerated when you forgot the words, it was very enjoyable. I think my version was better. We will see you after the break for more Robin Hood. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman.
好人的爱戴。罗宾汉，罗宾汉。罗宾汉。开头唱得太好了，我还以为不会好笑了。但后来你忘词了，开始走调的时候，真的非常搞笑。我觉得我的版本更好。我们休息之后见，继续聊罗宾汉。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。
And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our on our q a we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to the rest of the entertainment.com that's the rest is history tom holland didn't sing us in after the break which i think we can all agree it was just as well but tom we are now i could do another song no don't well i mean maybe at the end maybe at the end or a poem if you have a poem i do have a poem. I do have a poem. Oh, that's exciting. So we have discussed in the first half how the legend began with ballads and then went through various iterations. It's actually a much more complicated story even than the one we've told,
我们共同主持《娱乐至死》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和八卦的地方。在我们的问答环节中，我们会拉开娱乐界的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听、额外单集以及抢先获得现场门票的权限，请前往 theresaentertainment.com ——那是“历史至死”（the rest is history），汤姆·霍兰德在休息之后没有为我们唱歌，我想大家都会同意，这也是件好事。不过，汤姆，我们现在——我可以再唱一首歌。不，别唱了。好吧，我的意思是，也许在最后？也许在最后，或者如果你有一首诗的话。我确实有一首诗。我确实有一首诗。哦，太令人兴奋了。所以在上半部分，我们讨论了传奇是如何从民谣开始，然后经历了各种演变。这其实是一个比我们讲述的要复杂得多的故事，
isn't it? There's so much more stuff about ballads and folk stories and all this sort of stuff that we haven't had time to do. But let's now talk about historical reality. So Tom, we had a question from Aurelius and one of our members, one of the Rest Is History Club members on our Discord chat channel, which you can all sign up to if you go to restishistorypod.com. Brilliantly done. Robbing from the rich to give to the poor. Exactly. Now, Aurelius says, did Robin Hood really exist? What's the answer?
对吧？关于民谣、民间故事还有诸如此类的东西，还有太多我们没时间讲的内容了。但现在我们来谈谈历史现实。所以，汤姆，我们收到了来自奥勒留（Aurelius）以及我们的一位会员——“历史至死”俱乐部在Discord聊天频道上的成员的问题，大家只要访问 restishistorypod.com 就可以注册加入。干得漂亮。劫富济贫。正是如此。现在，奥勒留问，罗宾汉真的存在过吗？答案是什么？
So essentially, there are three answers to the question of where does Robin Hood come from? Oh, this is disappointingly elusive. He's entirely fictional, product of ballads and literary traditions. Yeah. Or there's a real Robin Hood who actually existed. Or a theory that was very, very popular in the mid-20th century. He's the expression of some kind of ancient pagan figure, the Green Man or something like that. So that's the idea that's picked up on something we didn't mention at all in the first half, which is the 1980s TV series Robin of Sherwood.
所以本质上，关于罗宾汉从何而来这个问题，有三个答案。哦，这真是令人失望地难以捉摸。他完全是虚构的，是民谣和文学传统的产物。是的。或者有一个真正存在过的真实的罗宾汉。或者还有一种在20世纪中期非常非常流行的理论：他是某种古代异教神祇的化身，比如绿人（Green Man）之类的人物。这个想法承接了我们在上半部分完全没有提到的一点，那就是1980年代的电视剧《舍伍德的罗宾》（Robin of Sherwood）。
Robin, the hooded man. Thanks for that, Tom. That was was clad that was really enjoyable in that version he is commissioned by her and the hunter that's right to be a sort of champion for the for the for deep england or something so uh that that was pushed by margaret murray who has cropped up occasionally on this podcast she was an egyptologist terrible theories. So she was the one who argued that witches were secret pagans and all that kind of stuff. And she argued that Robin Hood is the image of the devil. His hood is in some way associated with horns.
罗宾，那个戴兜帽的男人。谢谢你，汤姆。那部剧真让人身临其境。那个版本真的很有趣。在那个版本中，他受赫恩（Herne）——也就是猎人——的委托，成为英格兰腹地或某种类似象征的守护者。所以，这个观点是由玛格丽特·默里（Margaret Murray）推崇的，她偶尔也会在这档播客中出现。她是一位埃及古物学家，有着糟糕透顶的理论。所以就是她提出巫师是秘密异教徒诸如此类的论点。她还认为罗宾汉是魔鬼的化身。他的兜帽在某种程度上与角有关。
And this is Balderdash, isn't it, basically? But actually, the person who originally comes up with this theory is Jacob Grimm, as in the Brothers Grimm, who suggests that the name of Robin Hood comes from Woden. Right. That's not right either. No, it's not right. So I think we can basically park that theory. I don't think that's true. I don't think we can park it. I think we should just throw it in the gutter and trample it. Trample on it. Jump on it. Yes. Set it on fire. So that leaves two possibilities,
这纯粹是胡说八道，对吧？但实际上，最初提出这个理论的人是雅各布·格林（Jacob Grimm），也就是格林兄弟中的雅各布，他暗示罗宾汉的名字来自奥丁（Woden）。对的。这也是不对的。不，这不对。所以我想我们基本上可以把这个理论搁置了。我不认为这是真的。我觉得我们不能只是搁置它。我们应该把它扔进阴沟里，然后践踏它。践踏它。狠狠地踩它。是的。把它烧掉。所以这就剩下两种可能性：
that there's a real Robin Hood, or he is the product of literary traditions. Or I suppose the third one, that he's a fusion of two, of both those. So as we said, the earliest mention of Robin Hood as Robin Hood, you know, an outlaw, who is the hero of first ballads, is in this poem, Piers Plowman, fast Middle English epic. Written in the 1370s.
要么存在一个真正的罗宾汉，要么他是文学传统的产物。或者我想还有第三种可能，他结合了这二者。正如我们所说，最早将罗宾汉作为罗宾汉——你知道的，一个作为早期民谣英雄的江洋大盗——提及的，是在这首长诗《农夫皮尔斯》（Piers Plowman）中，这是一部早期中古英语史诗。写于1370年代。
In that, the way that he's described, it's clear that his legends are very, very popular, and that lots of people know him. And Langland, as we said, is writing in the West Midlands. So that's kind of evidence that his stories are known in that part of England, certainly, in the mid-14th century. So presumably, you can, at the very least, push it back several generations, probably to the beginning of the 14th century. So presumably you can at the very least push it back several generations, probably to the beginning of the 14th century. But how much further back than that can you go? And as you said in the first part, there is evidence that the name Robin Hood is being used as a kind of generic name for outlaws. And so there's an example of this from Berkshire in the
在诗中，对他的描述清楚地表明，他的传奇故事非常非常受欢迎，许多人都知道他。而且正如我们所说，兰格兰（Langland）是在西米德兰兹郡写作的。这在某种程度上证明，至少在14世纪中期，英格兰的那部分地区已经知道了他的故事。所以据此推测，你至少可以把他的存在推回到好几个世代以前，大概可以追溯到14世纪初。所以据此推测，你至少可以把他的存在推回到好几个世代以前，大概可以追溯到14世纪初。但还能追溯得更早吗？正如你在第一部分所说的那样，有证据表明“罗宾汉”这个名字被用作江洋大盗的泛称。1260年代伯克郡就有这样一个例子。
1260s. Yes, I've seen this. Yeah. That again must imply that the origins of this are earlier, because all the earliest references are to Robin being either in Sherwood or Yorkshire. So this is a man who, his name was William. He was the son of somebody called Robert Lefebvre, Robert the Smith. And he was part of a gang. And he was, there was a penalty imposed or something. There was, his chattels were meant to have been seized. The entry in the sort of the King's Remembrance's memoranda roll, I don't actually know what that is. But anyway, the entry, whoever wrote it,
是的，我见过这个。是的。这再次暗示了它的起源更早，因为所有最早的记载都说罗宾要么在舍伍德，要么在约克郡。所以这是一个名叫威廉的人。他是某个叫罗伯特·勒费弗尔（Robert Lefebvre，意为铁匠罗伯特）的儿子。他是某个帮派的成员。然后，似乎被处以了某种惩罚。他的动产本该被没收。在国王纪念使的备忘录卷轴上的记录——我其实不知道那是什么。不过总之，那段记录，不管是谁写的，
wrote him down as William Robber Hood. But Robber Hood not being his name, but being a sort of, just what kind of a person he was. Yeah. So there is a guy, a man called Robin Hod, who in the Yorker sizes of 1225 to six is described as a fugitivus, so Latin for outlaw. So that is the only example we have of someone called Robert Robin Hood who appears in a legal record who is described as an outlaw. One of the things that's happened since the 19th century is that people have gone through all the medieval records, the court rolls and the Assizes and all that kind of stuff, looking for people called Robin Hood. A popular candidate is a guy called Robert Hood, who appears in the court rolls of Wakefield in 1316, 1317. Edward II is in the north around that region in 1323. We're told in
把他写成了“威廉·罗伯·胡德”（William Robber Hood）。但“Robber Hood”并不是他的名字，而是一种描述他是什么样的人的称呼。是的。所以确实有这么一个人，一个叫罗宾·霍德（Robin Hod）的人，在1225到1226年的约克郡民诉法庭记录中，他被描述为一个“fugitivus”，也就是拉丁语中的“逃犯”。所以这是我们唯一的例子，记录了一个出现在法律记录中、被称为逃犯、名字叫罗伯特/罗宾汉的人。自19世纪以来发生的一件事是，人们翻遍了所有中世纪的记录，包括法院卷轴、民诉法庭记录等等，寻找名字叫罗宾汉的人。一个热门的候选人是一个叫罗伯特·胡德（Robert Hood）的人，他出现在1316年、1317年的韦克菲尔德（Wakefield）法院卷轴中。爱德华二世在1323年前往该地区北部巡视。我们在
the guest that the name of the king is Edward, though not Richard, it's Edward. But this is pretty kind of desperate stuff, really. But there's also a man, have you not seen this man called Robert of Weatherby? Have we talked about him? So he was captured in 1225, his body suspended in chains by the Sheriff of Yorkshire. It's the sort of right place-ish, he's the right kind of, he's called Robert. There's a guy called Robertbert godbird who um served under simon de montfort at evesham that is quite an early tradition who becomes an outlaw so these are all kind of figures that are lurking around but none of them really fit what you do definitely
《盖斯特诗集》（The Geste）中得知，国王的名字叫爱德华，虽然不是理查，但确实是爱德华。但这真的有点像是绝望地强行寻找关联。不过还有另一个人，你没见过这个叫韦瑟比的罗伯特（Robert of Weatherby）的人吗？我们讨论过他吗？他于1225年被捕，其尸体被约克郡治安官悬挂在铁链上。这地方差不多对，人也差不多对，他叫罗伯特。还有一个叫罗伯特·戈德伯德（Robert Godbird）的人，曾在伊夫舍姆（Evesham）效力于西蒙·德·蒙福特（Simon de Montfort），这是一个相当早的传统，他后来成了一个江洋大盗。所以这些都是潜藏在史料中的人物，但没有一个能真正符合。不过你确凿拥有的是，
have is very ancient traditions of stories about outlaws seem to be quite popular so you've got hero of the wake would be a classic so lots of people asked about similar so hero of the wakes descendant tom is a listener to the rest is history yes you mentioned i told you i've mentioned him before because he was that family was also involved in murdering the princes in the tower he raised an eyebrow i think it's fair to say at me when i saw him after that podcast and he thought his family had been greatly introduced anyway hero of the wake was a tremendous fellow wasn't he because he was a saxon holding out against the normans yeah or was he are you going to tell me that's yeah no i think that's no i think that's true yes there's a tradition isn't there and it's
关于江洋大盗的古老传说似乎非常受欢迎——比如赫里沃克（Hereward the Wake）就是一个经典的例子。所以很多人问过类似的问题——赫里沃克的后代，汤姆，正是“历史至死”的听众。是的，你提过，我跟你说过我之前提过他，因为那个家族也参与了谋杀塔克高塔中的王子。当我在那期播客之后见到他时，我想他冲我挑了挑眉毛，他觉得他的家族被大大地误解了。不管怎样，赫里沃克是个了不起的家伙，对吧？因为他是对抗诺曼人的盎格鲁-撒克逊人。是的。或者他是吗？你打算告诉我那是……是的，不，我想那是真的。是的，有一种传统，对吧？不仅在英国，
not just in england so no you know lots of countries have them of sort of bandit outlaw kind of hero of the commonwealth against the sort of the powerful and and do you think robin hood is is just part of that general sort of European tradition? The trickster hero, that kind of... I think the idea of outlaws as heroes is definitely... It's there with Hero of the Wake. It's there with a group of brothers called the Folevilles. The Folevilles?
你知道的，许多国家都有这种传统——某种反抗强权的绿林好汉、江洋大盗式的平民英雄。你觉得罗宾汉只是这种普遍的欧洲传统的一部分吗？那个耍滑头的英雄，那种……我觉得江洋大盗作为英雄的想法绝对是存在的。赫里沃克就是这样。还有一群被称为福勒维尔（Folevilles）的兄弟。福勒维尔？
The Folevilles, who are kind of basically delinquent members of the gentry who take to the woods. And who, again, Langland mentions, who are essentially seen as being more honest than the law enforcement agents. So that's a kind of key part of the appeal. Yeah, William Tell, obviously, in Switzerland. So yeah, so there are lots of examples of this across medieval Europe. I mean, I don't think that there is a smoking gun among any of these candidates. I think there's just a sense of this being a kind of popular tradition and that Robin Hood, for whatever reason, comes to be the generic name that is applied to the figure of outlaws. So that then
福勒维尔家族，他们基本上是遁入森林的士绅阶层中的不良成员。而且正如兰格兰所提到的，他们基本上被认为比执法人员更诚实。所以这是其吸引力的一个关键部分。是的，瑞士的威廉·泰尔（William Tell）显然也是。所以，是的，整个中世纪的欧洲有很多这样的例子。我的意思是，我不认为在所有这些候选人中能找到决定性的铁证。我认为这只是一种普遍的传统意识，出于某种原因，“罗宾汉”成了适用于江洋大盗形象的泛称。所以这就
begs the question of how and why and when do these stories start to take the form that they do? And when do they start to be spoken and repeated and elaborated on? And I think the answer to that is focused on the fact that these stories are in English. The tradition of these stories of people going out into woods, of people having adventures, this is a French courtly tradition. So the stories of King Arthur's Knights, all that kind of stuff, but not just King Arthur's Knights. There are traditions of, you know, Fablo and all kinds of things like that, that are French. So English is not a language in which these are being reproduced at court or anything like that. What is the moment when this might change? And Leslie Coote, who's written this fantastic book, came out a couple
引出了一个问题：这些故事是如何、为何以及在何时开始呈现出它们后来的形态的？它们是什么时候开始被讲述、重复并详细阐述的？我认为这个问题的答案集中在这些故事是用英语写的这一点上。关于人们进入森林、经历冒险的故事传统，这原本是一个法国的宫廷传统。所以亚瑟王骑士的故事等等，不仅限于亚瑟王骑士。还有诸如“法布利奥”（Fabliau）等各种法国传统的民间故事。所以英语并不是宫廷里用来重新演绎这些故事的语言。这种情况可能在什么时候发生改变呢？莱斯利·库特（Leslie Coote）几年前出版了一本精彩绝伦的书。
of years ago. She suggests that the obvious moment is in the reign of Edward I, who is fighting the French. He doesn't have lands on France anymore, and he's fighting the Welsh, and he's fighting the Scots. And he wants to emphasise Englishness and the role of English, and that he could speak English, that perhaps this is the point where French traditions start to be transliterated into English. And perhaps that is the moment. She also has a further fascinating thesis as to who Robin might be, and in particular, why he's in the wood and who his true lord might be. Oh, Tom, this is so exciting. And why he might be an outlaw. So we talked about Maid Marian, and I was kind of rather
她提出，最明显的契机是在爱德华一世统治时期，当时他正在与法国作战。他不再在法国拥有领地，他正在与威尔士人作战，也在与苏格兰人作战。他想要强调英格兰本土的特色以及英语的作用，他自己也会说英语，也许这正是法国传统开始被音译为英语的节点。也许这就是那个时刻。关于罗宾究竟是谁，特别是他为什么会在森林里以及他真正的领主可能是谁，她还有一个更令人着迷的论点。哦，汤姆，这太令人兴奋了。以及他为什么会成为一个江洋大盗。我们谈到了梅德·玛丽安（Maid Marian），我之前对她的出处含糊其辞，还阻止了你对此做进一步的探究。你确实阻止了。我觉得你不是含糊其辞。你只是粗鲁。我很粗鲁。在与“Maid Marian”连用时，“Maid”这个词还有什么别的含义？哦，天哪，你又把它扯回基督教去了。难以置信。你不会要说梅德·玛丽安就是圣母玛利亚吧？是吗？我是。是的，我就是这么认为的。这真是标准的汤姆·霍兰德式发言。
mysterious about where she might come from and block down your inquiries about that. You did. I don't think you were mysterious. You were just rude. I was rude. What's another word for maid in the sense that it's used with Maid Marian? Oh, God almighty, you've turned it back to Christianity. Unbelievable. You're going to say Maid Marian is the Virgin Mary. Are you? I am. Yes, I am. It's textbook Tom Holland.
我对此感到太兴奋了。我一直憋着没说。延迟满足。接着说。所以这也是一个法国传统。它们被称为“pastorelles”（田园牧歌）。这是一个关于一个名叫玛丽安（Marion）的牧羊女的传统。她有一个情人或仆人叫罗宾（Robin）。很显然，这是
I'm so excited about this. I've been saving it up. Delayed gratification. Go on. So this, again, is a French tradition. They're called pastorelles. And this is a tradition of a shepherdess called Marion. And she has a lover or servant called Robin. It is clear that this is a kind of a metaphor for the relationship of
基督徒个人与其同圣母玛利亚关系的一种隐喻。莱斯利·库特的理论本质上是说，这就是罗宾汉故事的终极起源。他之所以成为江洋大盗，是因为他的领主是圣母玛利亚。而圣母玛利亚在这些故事中基本上是一个恶作剧者式的角色。莱斯利·库特在这些民间传说中将她描述为坚韧、教条主义、狡猾、喧闹、务实、现实，甚至在某些时候表现得明显不道德和好胜复仇。罗宾汉效忠的是一个非常叛逆、危险的女性领主。如果你回想那个故事，《罗宾汉与僧侣》（Robin Hood and the Monk），那是最早的一个故事，整个情节都围绕着他进城去做弥撒、向圣母表达敬意展开。而她却说，罗宾汉既不是
the individual Christian and his relationship to the Virgin Mary. The theory of Leslie Coote is that essentially this is the ultimate origin for the stories of Robin Hood. The reason that he is an outlaw is that his Lord is the Virgin Mary. And the Virgin Mary in these stories is basically a kind of trickster. Leslie Coote describes her in these popular tales as being tough, legalistic, sly, loud, practical, realistic, even apparently amoral and vengeful at times. Robin Hood serves a very unruly, dangerous female lord. And if you think of that story, Robin Hood and the Monk, the very earliest one, the whole plot revolves around him going into town to attend mass to pay his devotions to the Mary. And she says, Robin Hood is neither a
自由斗士，也不是社会强盗——这正是今天人们经常对他的解读。罗宾只是一个仆人。真正具有社会政治意义上潜在危险的，是他的领主圣母玛利亚。玛利亚是一个伟大世家的领主，其宅邸位于森林之中，或者可能恰好在森林之外。等等。玛利亚是领主？我的意思是，所有这些。这一切听起来都有点诡异，不是吗？这确实很诡异。圣母玛利亚实际上是一个住在豪华庄园或其他地方的贵族妇女或男子的这种桥段在中世纪故事中是个常见的母题吗？所有早期故事都清楚地表明，罗宾对圣母充满虔诚。他们之所以不交代他的背景故事，是因为他之所以待在绿林中，只是因为他是圣母玛利亚的仆人。这就是这个论点。当然，掩盖这一点的正是宗教改革，因为随着宗教改革，这一切都烟消云散了。罗宾为什么待在绿林中、他为什么对圣母如此虔诚的底层逻辑，不得不被抹去。但为什么在宗教改革之前那些15世纪后期的民谣中没有体现这一点呢？那是宗教改革前的事。僧侣们有大量的恶行。这确实存在。但圣母玛利亚并没有出现在滑稽剧（jest）中，对吧？民谣，那是宗教改革前的事。僧侣有大量的恶行。确实有。但圣母玛利亚并没有出现在滑稽剧里，对吧？
freedom fighter nor a social bandit, ways in which he's frequently interpreted today. Robin is just a servant. It is his lord, the Virgin Mary, who is potentially dangerous in a socio-political sense. Mary is the lord of a great household whose seat lies in or possibly just beyond the forest. Hold on. Mary is the lord. I mean, all that. That's all a bit weird, isn't it? It is weird. Is that a common motif in medieval tales that the Virgin Mary is actually a noble woman or man living in a big manor or something? All the early stories make it clear that Robin's devotion is to the Virgin. The reason why they don't give a backstory for him, he just is in the Greenwood because he is the servant of the
我的意思是，她不在，或者至少不是很明显。是的，在所有这些故事中，罗宾的虔诚都是献给圣母的。这是一个贯穿始终的主题，当然，我们往往不会注意到，因为，你知道的，我们只把它看作中世纪的装饰。我觉得挺有趣的是，如果你想想罗宾汉在人们想象中扮演的角色，其中蕴含着一种深沉的怀旧情绪。绝对的。我的意思是，他某种程度上体现了梅里英格兰（Merry England）。
Virgin Mary. That's the thesis. And of course, what makes this occluded is the Reformation, because with the Reformation, this goes out of the window. And essentially the logic as to why Robin is in the Greenwood, the reason why he is particularly devoted to the Virgin, that has to be erased. But why isn't that in those ballads then, before the Reformation, the late 15th century ballads? That's pre-Reformation. Great deal of villainy from monks. It is there. But the Virgin Mary isn't there in the jest, is she? Iads, that's pre-Reformation. Monk, a great deal of villainy from monks. It is there. But the Virgin Mary isn't there in the jest, is she?
梅里英格兰，正是如此。你知道的，饕餮鹿肉、欢乐喜庆还有诸如此类的一切。而且在某种意义上，我认为罗宾成了新教传道者的敌人。他开始被边缘化、被淘汰的原因之一，是因为他与圣母的联系让新教徒很难将他融入自己的理念中。此外，他还与这些五朔节（Mayday）庆祝活动联系在一起，是的，这些被视为……你知道的，被视为异教的、天主教色彩的等等。基本上，在16世纪的进程中，他变得不再流行，他变得……也就是在这个时候，他开始
I mean, she's not, or at least not explicitly. Yeah, Robin's devotion is to the Virgin in all these stories. It's the kind of running theme that, of course, we tend not to notice because, you know, we just kind of see it as medieval window dressing. I think it is kind of interesting that if you think about the role that Robin Hood plays in kind of the imagination, there's a deep vein of nostalgia there. Definitely. I mean, he kind of embodies Mary England.
变得稍微有点阶级属性，他开始与下层阶级、与未受教育的人联系在一起。也就是在这个时候，16世纪末，人们为他虚构了一个贵族的背景。作为一个贵族。对的，没错。所以，汤姆，你或莱斯利·库特的这个论点，跟爱德华一世的那些事是怎么契合的呢？
Mary England, exactly. You know, feasting on venison and, you know, merriness and waha and all that kind of stuff. And there is a sense, I think, in which Robin becomes the enemy of Protestant preachers. And one of the reasons why he starts to be phased out is because the association with the Virgin makes him awkward for Protestants to start to integrate into their idea. And there's also the association of him with these kind of mayday festivities yeah these are seen as kind of you know and and papist and all kinds of things basically over the course of the 16th century he becomes out of fashion he he becomes you know and this is where he starts
所以有这些关于他和玛丽安的法国故事，而玛丽安就是圣母玛利亚。为什么在爱德华一世统治时期、在我们与法国交战时，它们变得如此根深蒂固？他在鼓励将这些不同的体裁和诗歌风格音译为英语。所以他试图将那些非常受欢迎的东西“本土化”。
to become kind of a bit of class a uh he becomes associated with lower classes with the uneducated and that's when he's kind of backwards menvented at the end of the 16th century. As a nobleman. Yeah, exactly. So Tom, how does that thesis of yours, or indeed Leslie Coutts, how does that fit in with this stuff about Edward I?
是的。所以如果它们是用英语写的，那么它们就可以开始在酒馆里流传开来，以至于到了14世纪后期，酒馆里的人们都对它们耳熟能详。所以当这些故事刚开始时，并不是在酒馆里流传的吗？这是你的观点吗？它们的定位比那更高雅？是的，因为它们是用法语写的，所以这些是宫廷传统。因此，你知道的，只有上层阶级才会熟悉它们。
So there are these French stories of him and Marianne, and Marianne being the Virgin Mary. Why do they become so deep rooted in the reign of Edward I when we're fighting the French? He is encouraging the transliteration of these various genres and verse styles into English. So he's trying to anglicise what are very popular.
所以罗宾汉实际上是虚构的。所以你实际上推翻了你之前的……所以你认为从根本上说他是一个文学构建？他是一个法国文学构建？是这样吗？我认为他是一个与人们对江洋大盗的热情相融合的文学构建，所以我觉得他是一个——如果你愿意的话——盎格鲁-法国的发明。那是法国式的笑声吗？我猜是的。所以我们从听众那里得到的所有这些问题，你知道的，他是约克郡人吗？他是这个吗？他是那个吗？他真的是个杀人如麻的强盗吗？你会说所有这些听众提出的问题，你知道的，他是约克郡人吗？他是这个吗？他是那个吗？他真的是个杀人如麻的强盗吗？你会说所有这些问题都完全抓错了重点，因为实际上根本没有……
Yeah. And so if they're in English, then they can start to be repeated in pubs, so that by the late 14th century, people in pubs are familiar with them. So when the stories first start, they're not being repeated in pubs. Is that the claim? That they're more upmarket than that? Yeah, so these are courtly traditions because they're in French. So, you know, it's only the upper classes who would be familiar with them.
嗯，我不认为它们抓错了重点。我不认为它们抓错了重点，因为我认为所有这些问题实际上都在迎合这样一个事实：人们对这个人物有着一种与生俱来的迷恋。你所提出的问题往往会衍生出更多的
So Robin Hood is actually fictional. So you've actually gone back on your previous... So you think deep down he's a literary construct. He's a French literary construct. Is that right? I think he's a literary construct who blends with a popular enthusiasm for outlaws so i think he's yeah he's a kind of anglo-french invention if you like is that a sort of french laugh i thought so so all these questions that we've got from listeners you know was he a yorkshireman was he this was he that was he a really a murderous brigand was he you would say all these questions that we've got from listeners, you know, was he a Yorkshireman? Was he this?
传统。为了准备这期节目我读的另一本书，就是一个绝对精彩绝伦的例子。我向你推荐它，多米尼克，我也向所有的听众推荐它。这是凯·罗伯茨（Kai Roberts）写的一本书，从他的推特照片来看，他绝对不是个诺曼人。他是个快乐的自耕农。这本书叫《严重的担忧：罗宾汉最终安息之地的愚蠢与民间传说》（Grave Concerns, The Follies and Folklore of Robin Hood's Final Resting Place）。这本书聚焦于罗宾之死的故事，这个情节在电影中通常不太常见。肖恩·康纳利（Sean Connery）的那部电影确实着墨于他的死。这个故事，事实上，最早在《盖斯特诗集》中被提及。
Was he that? Was he really a murderous brigand? You would say all these questions are completely beside the point because actually there is no, you know. Well, I don't think they're beside the point. I don't think they're beside the point because I think that all these questions are kind of battening onto the fact that there is an inherent fascination about the figure. The questions that you ask tend to generate further
所以很早的时候，它就描述了他是如何被一个邪恶的女人——柯克利斯（Kirklees）修道院的修女院院长所欺骗的。柯克利斯是一个真实存在的地方，是奔宁山脉约克郡一侧的一个修女院，因为对一位骑士——也就是她的情人唐卡斯特的罗杰爵士（Sir Roger of Doncaster）的爱，她与罗宾有很近的亲缘关系。愿灾难降临他们两人头上。
traditions. One other book that I read in preparation for this is an absolutely brilliant, brilliant example of this. I commend it to you, Dominic, and I commend it to all the listeners. It's a book by Kai Roberts, who judging by his Twitter photo is very much not a Norman. He's a kind of jolly yeoman. And it's called Grave Concerns, the Follies and Folklore of Robin Hood's Final Resting Place. And this is focused on the idea of the story of Robin's death, which doesn't tend to feature very often in the film. So there is the Sean Connery one that does focus on his death. And the story, in fact, it's first mentioned in The Guest.
他们密谋要除掉罗宾汉，商量着如何最好地完成那件勾当，好成为他的谋杀犯。这时，善良的罗宾站在原地开口说道：“明天我必须去柯克利斯放血治病。”唐卡斯特的罗杰爵士和修女院长躺在一起，他们在那里通过虚伪的阴谋背叛了善良的罗宾汉。这就是他被表妹放血的故事，罗宾以为自己的病能治好，但修女并没有治好他，鲜血直流。在故事的进一步演变中，罗宾吹响了他的号角，小约翰赶到了，他想要烧毁修女院并
So very early, it describes how he was tricked by means of a wicked woman, the prioress of Kirklees. So Kirklees is an actual place, a nunnery in the Yorkshire side of the Pennines, that was his close kin for the love of a knight, Sir Roger of Doncaster, who was her lover. May evil befall them both.
屠杀所有的修女。但罗宾说服了他不要这么做。接着，他抓起弓，射出了一支箭。那就是罗宾被埋葬的地方。在柯克利斯修女院的土地上有一块石头，显然非常古老。随着修道院的解散，这块石头成了一个中心点，周围建起了观赏花园和饰楼等等。事实上，斯坦利·巴尔的温（Stanley Baldwin）还发表过一次演讲，他可以说是“历史至死”的朋友，是的，就在这片土地上。汤姆，我其实查过那次演讲，讲得好吗？对文本来说……它并没有像我希望的那样以罗宾汉为主题。哦，那太遗憾了。内容主要关于……帝国以及……声音的重要性。所以主题很大，但跟这段对话无关。凯·罗伯茨对此给出了精彩的讲述。
They conspired together, Robin Hood to slay, and how they might best do that deed, his murderers to be. Then up spoke good Robin in the place where he stood. Tomorrow I must go to Kirklees to be skillfully let blood. Sir Roger of doncaster by the prioress he lay and there they betrayed good robin hood through their false play so that's the story of him going being bled by his by his cousin and robin thinks he's going to be cured and she isn't and blood pours away and in further elaborations of the story robin blows on his horn little comes, he wants to burn down the priory and
我的意思是，他把所有这些内容写得极其有趣，展现了这些传统如何在几个世纪里逐渐积累、如何受到质疑、如何被修正、如何不断发展。最棒的部分是，在1980年代和1990年代，罗宾汉的——这块据说标志着罗宾汉墓地的石头位于私有土地上。这个庄园归17世纪得到它的那个家族所有。所以它是无法进入的。
slaughter all the nuns. And Robin persuades him not to do that. But he reaches for his bow and fires the arrow. And that is where Robin is buried. And there is a stone in the grounds of Kirkley's Priory that is clearly very ancient. And with the dissolution of the monasteries, this stone becomes a kind of centre place of ornamental gardens and follies and so on in fact stanley baldwin gives a talk very much a friend of the rest of history yes in in in the grounds i've actually looked up that talk tom um is it good to the text it wasn't as robin hood themed as i'd hoped oh that's a shame it was mainly about um the empire and um the importance of sound. So great themes, but not relevant to this conversation. Kai Roberts gives a brilliant account of this.
约克郡崛起了一个压力集团，说我们应该有权进入那里。是的。而庄园主拒绝让他们进入。他们和庄园主之间的关系越来越恶化，我这里用“恶化”（bad blood）这个词是有深意的，因为最后他们竟然请了一个人在70年代参与过海客高地公墓（Highgate Cemetery）争端的人担任他们的会长，那人曾声称海客高地公墓闹吸血鬼。他对这个非常感兴趣，因为修女院长给罗宾汉放血的这个桥段。于是他提出了这样一个论点：修女院长其实是个吸血鬼，把罗宾也变成了一个吸血鬼，他们一直在盘桓在这片庄园的土地上。他们甚至私自闯入，去了墓地遗址，还看到了修女院长。
I mean, he makes all this stuff incredibly interesting, the way in which these traditions have kind of gradually kind of accumulated over the centuries, the way that they've been questioned, the way they've been revised, the way that they grow. The best bit of all is that in the 1980s and 1990s, Robin Hood's, this stone that supposedly marks the grave of Robin Hood is in private land. The estate is owned by the family that got hold of it in the 17th century. So it is not accessible.
我会读一下对她的描述。一个女人，她的眼睛疯狂而阴暗，像蝙蝠一样嵌在她苍白的脸上，她黑色的修女长袍发出诡异的扑扇声，同时她的眼睛闪烁着血红而恶毒的光芒，露出了在龇牙咧嘴的血红嘴唇间显得尖锐而洁白的牙齿。等等，这是在1980年代发生的？是的。修女院长当时还在活动。显然，修女院长至今仍然在外游荡。
And a pressure group grew up in Yorkshire saying we should have access to it yeah and the um the owner of the estate refused to let them come in and there's kind of increasingly bad blood between them and i use the word blood advisedly because in the end they ended up getting as their president someone who had been involved in the 70s in highgate cemetery arguing that highgate cemetery had was haunted by a vampire. And he was terribly interested in it because of this idea of the prioress bleeding Robin Hood. And so he came up with the thesis that the prioress was actually a vampire and had turned Robin into a vampire, and that they were haunting the grounds of this estate. They kind of broke in and went to the site of the grave and saw the prioress.
如果罗宾也是个吸血鬼的话，那他大概也还在。但这真是一个绝妙的例子，展现了这些传统如何在今天依然在不断衍生出新的传统。在你刚才讲话的时候，我在想罗宾汉催生出的一个新传统，汤姆，一个对你来说非常亲切的传统，正如听众们可能还记得的那样。
I will read the description of it. A woman, her eyes dark mad, set in her pale face like a bat, her black nun's robes flapping eerily while her eyes flashed red and venomous, her teeth bared sharp and white between snarling blood red lips. Hold on, this was in the 1980s? Yeah. The prioress was still going. The prioress is still out there, apparently. And as presumably must Robin Hood be,
所以罗宾汉是一个拥有双重身份的人。他会穿上一套行头。他和其他同样穿着行头、拥有双重身份的人混在一起。所以他基本上是个超级英雄，对吧？从某种意义上说，是的。他是蜘蛛侠的祖先。我想是的。是的，这倒是个有趣的设想。我来告诉你他还是谁的祖先。我刚才听你说话时笑了起来，因为我突然完全想不起来了，我曾经为一家非常受欢迎的报纸
if he's a vampire as well. But it's a kind of brilliant example of the way in which these traditions are still generating new traditions. I was thinking while you were talking about a new tradition that Robin Hood has generated, Tom, one that's very close to your heart, as listeners may remember.
写过一篇两千字的文章，对比了罗宾汉和劳尔·莫特（Raoul Moat）的人生轨迹。哦，莫蒂！我还真记得莫蒂。所以他是一个例子——现在这对我们的海外听众来说毫无意义，甚至连解释都毫无意义——但劳尔·莫特，如果你还记得的话，当他四处躲藏的时候，
So Robin Hood is a man who has two identities. He dresses up in an outfit. He hangs out with other people who are dressing up in outfits who have two identities. So he's basically a superhero, isn't he? He is, in a way. He's the ancestor of Spider-Man. I suppose he is. Yeah, that's a nice thought. I'll tell you who he's also the ancestor of. I started laughing while you were talking. I had completely blanked from my mind that I once wrote a 2000 word essay
他藏在林子里还是什么地方，对吧？加扎（Gaza）还带着一些鸡肉和一根鱼竿去看望他。是的，没错。你可以看出这很容易本身就变成一首民间民谣，不是吗？人们——这个名不见经传的作家，多米尼克·桑德布鲁克（Dominic Sandbrook）。是的，没错。真的有过劳尔·莫特这个人吗？
for a very popular newspaper comparing the lives of Robin Hood and Raoul Moat Oh, Moaty! I do remember Moaty So he was an example, now this will mean nothing to our overseas listeners there's no point even trying to explain it but Raoul Moat, if you remember when he was hiding out
每日邮报。好吧，总之。这个人真的存在过吗？对。他们之中真的有人存在过吗？谁知道呢。所以我们并没有真正解开谜团。我还以为我们会解开这个谜团呢。
he was hiding out in the ward or something, wasn't he? And Gaza visited him with some chicken and a fishing rod. Yeah, that's right. You could see how that could easily become a folk ballad in and of itself, couldn't it? And people – this obscure writer, Dominic Sandbrick. Yeah, right, exactly. Was there a real Raoul Moat?
我想我们已经解开了。好吧，我的意思是，我觉得你的解决方案——或者说他是法国人的那个解决方案……你不喜欢那个？文学公式。我一点也不喜欢。我觉得我被骗了。我还以为你会，你知道的，会在1215年左右的巴恩斯利（Barnsley）找到某个屠夫什么的，那绝对是……是的，好吧。他是个吸血鬼。他可能是个吸血鬼。是的，这挺令人兴奋的。我的意思是，这相当不错。我能以一首诗来结尾吗？我觉得如果你这么做，
Ye daily mail. Yeah, anyway. Did this man really exist? Right. Did any of man really exist? Right. Did any of them really exist? Who knows? So we haven't really solved. I thought we would solve the mystery.
将完全符合这档播客的精神。好的，这首诗是我朋友尼古拉斯·霍格（Nicholas Hogg）写的，他是一个非常优秀的诗人，也是一个非常优秀的板球运动员，我就是这样认识他的。这首诗叫《长弓》（Longbow）。首先，我们翻过栅栏进入园艺中心，将其视为我们的城堡，然后偷走六英尺长的手杖，涉水穿过小溪来到学院路桥，
I think we have. Well, I mean, I find your solution or the solution that he's actually a French. You don't like that? Literary formula. I don't like that at all. I feel that I've been cheated. I thought you were going to, you know, you're going to have found some butcher in Barnsley in, you know,
在那里我们用尼龙绳把它绑紧，将它们弯成弓，弹奏着一件暴力与战争的乐器，这乐器曾受石器时代游牧民族、日本骑兵以及在ITV上穿着林肯绿服装的罗宾汉的青睐。当弓被拉开时，我们用飞镖羽翼和鸽子羽毛制作箭羽，然后用小折刀削尖箭头。针尖般锐利的碎片末端可以从指尖取血，将在国王的眼中高傲地挺立。针尖般锐利的碎片末端可以从指尖取血，将在国王的眼中高傲地挺立。接着我们在树林里搜寻兔子，将箭杆
1215 or something that was definitely. Yeah, yeah. Well, he's a vampire. He might be a vampire. Yeah, that's exciting. I mean, that's quite good. Could I end with a poem? I think it would be entirely in keeping with the spirit of this podcast
深深地射入一个穿越时空的诺曼人身体里，让他从城垛上坠落。注意那件被穿透的盔甲，他在空中挥舞着四肢，那支飞箭就像一枚胸针别在他的心口。这写得很好，不是吗？非常好。是的。这是我希望结束的完美方式。好的。传统仍在继续。是的。好的。传统仍在继续。是的。
if you did. Okay, so this is written by my friend Nicholas Hogg, and he's a very good poet and a very good cricketer, just how I know him. And it's called Longbow. First, we climbed the fence into the garden centre, above to our castle, before stealing six-foot lengths of cane and wading through the brook to the College Road Bridge,
如果你愿意的话。好的，这是我的朋友尼古拉斯·霍格写的，他是一位非常优秀的诗人，也是一位非常优秀的板球运动员，这就是我认识他的方式。这首诗叫《长弓》。首先，我们翻过栅栏进入园艺中心，把它当作我们的城堡，然后偷走六英尺长的手杖，涉水穿过小溪来到学院路桥，
where we'd set them tight with an island string and flex them into bows, strumming an instrument of violence and war once favoured by Stone Age nomads, Japanese horsemen and Robin Hood, who wore Lincoln Green on ITV. When the bow was sprung, we fletched arrows with dart flights and pigeon feathers before shaving down the points with pen knives. Needle-sharp splinter ends that could draw blood from fingertips will stand proud in the eye of a king. Needle-sharp splinter ends that could draw blood from fingertips will stand proud in the eye of a king. Then we stalk the woods for rabbits, burying the
在那里我们用岛屿细绳把它们扎紧，并将它们弯曲成弓，弹奏着一件曾受到石器时代游牧民族、日本骑兵以及在独立电视台身穿林肯绿衣的罗宾汉青睐的暴力与战争乐器。当弓被拉开时，我们用飞镖羽翼和鸽子羽毛制作箭羽，然后用小折刀削尖箭头。针尖般锐利的木刺足以从指尖刺出血来，也足以傲然挺立在国王的眼中。针尖般锐利的木刺足以从指尖刺出血来，也足以傲然挺立在国王的眼中。然后我们在树林里搜寻兔子，把
shaft deep in a time-travelling Norman, falling from a battlement. Note the pierced armour as he paddles the air, the flight like a brooch pinned to his heart. It's good, isn't it? It's very good. Yeah. It's the perfect way I wish to end. Okay. The tradition lives on. Yeah. Okay. The tradition lives on. Yeah.
箭杆深深地射入一个从城垛上坠落的、穿越时空的诺曼人身体里。注意看他那被刺穿的盔甲在空中无力地划动，那飞羽就像一枚胸针别在他的胸口。很好，不是吗？非常棒。是的。这是我希望结束的完美方式。好的。传统代代相传。是的。好的。传统代代相传。是的。
I think the tradition lives on. I don't think we've really solved the mystery, and nor have we really grappled with all the complexities of Robin Hood, because it's a subject that could take hours of podcasting. He's a vampire. We've solved it. But we have more than exceeded our time. Yeah, we're not Dan Carlin, so we can't.
我认为这个传统依然存在。我觉得我们并没有真正解开这个谜团，也没有真正处理好罗宾汉的所有复杂性，因为这是一个可以讲好几个小时播客的主题。他是个吸血鬼。我们已经解开了。但我们的时间已经远远超出了。对，我们不是丹·卡林，所以我们不能这样做。
No, exactly. So on that bombshell, we'll see you next time. Goodbye. Bye-bye. carl in so we can't no exactly so on that bombshell we'll see you next time goodbye bye thanks for listening to the rest is history for bonus episodes early access ad free listening Early access, ad-free listening and access to our chat community. Please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment.
不，确实如此。伴随着这个重磅炸弹，我们下期再见。再见。拜拜。卡林，所以我们不能，不，确实如此，所以伴随着这个重磅炸弹，我们下期再见，再见，拜拜。感谢收听《The Rest Is History》，如需获取加更节目、提前收听、无广告收听、提前购票、无广告收听以及进入我们的聊天社区，请登录 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《The Rest Is Entertainment》。
It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets,
这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论以及一点八卦八卦。在我们的问答环节中，我们揭开娱乐的面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、加更节目以及提前购买现场门票，
head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本集还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。